alors j'aimerais vous souhaiter au nom
de la société des ingénieurs arts et
métiers et plus particulièrement du gpi
énergie tant président joseph cela qui
ne coopèrent avec nous ce soir
la bienvenue à cet événement organisé
avec the project et le pacte finances
climat 2020 donc je suis très heureux de
vous voir aussi nombreux pour parler
d'un sujet qui nous engage et nous
concerne tous le climat alors la
dépasser ce chiffre project a lancé son
manifeste pour décarbonés l'europe qui a
recueilli la signature de près de 3000
personnes dont les principaux dirigeants
politiques et économiques et plus
récemment l'initiative donc pas ce crime
à 2020 a également comment dire fait
beaucoup parler d'elle en europe
donc ces deux démarches ont en commun
d'appeler à faire du climat l'acce
principal d'un renouveau de l'union
européenne un an après qu'en est il il
ya pour faire ce bilan d'étape
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir d
accueil et d inviter pardon de grande
valeur donc madame amélie de montchalin
député de la 6e circonscription de
l'essonne si je ne me trompe pas voilà
messieurs vif cohen de l'initiative
finances qui m'a 2020 et monsieur jean
marc jancovici au bout de la rue et qui
va qui va nous retrouver qui va nous
retrouver d'ici quelques secondes
j'espère voilà vous alors sans plus
attendre je voulais si j'ajoute une
dernière chose c'est à moi de le dire
donc que cet événement s'inscrit dans le
cadre des consultations citoyennes pour
le futur de l'europe lancée fin avril
dernier par le président de la
république et ses consultations
citoyennes ont lu dans tous les pays de
l'union européenne
voilà et c'est pour vous dire que cette
rencontre fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
qui soit publiée
alors voilà je laisse la place à mathieu
et je salue jean marc excellente soirée
vous
merci romain je suis matthieu auzanneau
je dirais l'honneur de diriger le
chiffre project le chiffre project en
deux mots c'est un groupe de réflexion
qui tâchent de pousser à la roue de la
transition énergétique
on a
on a discuté échangé beaucoup avec les
gens qui ont été à l'initiative du pacte
finances climat depuis cet hiver
notamment aux jean jouzel et pierre
larrouturou qui me charge de vous
transmettre ses excuses il a eu c'est
dans sa famille qui l'a obligé à
renoncer à être avec nous ce soir
le pacte de finances climat on a été
assez séduit par cette initiative qui on
va en parler bien des égards assez
complémentaire de ce qu'on a cherché à
faire avec le chiffre project donc yves
cohen qui qui fait partie de l'équipe
qui anime d'initiative du pacte finances
qui m'a mais je voulais c'est
immédiatement la parole pour tâcher de
présenter le l'enjeu et les objectifs de
cette initiative très très bien bonsoir
b d'abord j'excuse je vous prie
d'excuser pierre larrouturou qui est
d'inspirer ses chères pyrénées mais pour
un événement douloureux parce que je
sais qu'ils vraiment il voulait être là
ce soir
alors c'est doublement dommage parce
qu'il voulait être là et puis que moi je
n'ai pas ni sow ni son pouvoir de
persuasion ni son nom ni son débit qui
permet de faire passer pour ce qu'ils
connaissent rapidement et efficacement
des idées importantes jean jouzel non
plus ne pouvait pas être là ce soir donc
désolé pont alors je crois que j'ai la
télécommande qui qui marche donc le
pacte finances climat je pense que
certains d'entre vous le connaissent
d'autres pages avaient le résumer
rapidement
je vais essayer de tenir dans les dix
minutes un quart d'heure qui me sont
impartis donc c'est un mouvement
c'est un mouvement une démarche de
citoyens qui va s'inscrire qui rejoint
bien d'ailleurs l'agenda et la démarche
citoyenne qui vient d'être lancé il
s'agit de mobiliser beaucoup de monde
autour d'eux
ce projet de mai autour si possible de
réponses concrètes faisable apportant
une réponse à cette crise mais également
comment vouloir à la crise à des risques
de crise financière également donc
beaucoup de gens ont déjà répondu on
commence juste par un petit coup ici si
je m'excuse c'est bête mais donc ça se
présente comme un devoir sur table
sachant que l'objectif est de réduire de
3 % les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qu'elle est notre score en 2010
cette réponse à -3%
réponse b voisin réponse est plus un
alors moins trois personnes - 1 + 1 bd
désolé c'est plus 3,2 bravo pour eux
bravo pour eux ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
facile et pourtant les enjeux bon je
commence à être perçue par tous les
citoyens parce qu'il ya des choses très
concrètes qui sont à portée de là à
portée de main donc je n'insiste pas
très longuement mais les choses
deviennent concrètes pour les citoyens
et ce à un rapport quand même avec un
autre sujet concret que les citoyens se
posent aujourd'hui la banque la banque
mondiale parle de 140 millions de
réfugiés climatiques à l'horizon 2050
quand on sait comme on peine sur la
situation actuelle ça des implications
économiques les assureurs et les
réassureurs chiffres héros chiffrés et
ça se compte les enjeux sont les enjeux
sont lourds le nombre d'incidents est
l'heureux et leur gravité grimpe donc on
est dans un constat ou les émissions
continuent à augmenter et où le temps
pour agir commencent à se rétrécir parce
qu'il ya des effets il ya un certain
nombre de mécanismes auto amplificateur
donc jean jouzel l'expliquerai mieux que
moi mais la fonte des la fonte des
glaces enlève d une couverture blanche
qui qui en est qui par conséquence
diminué les réflexions et augmentent
leur échauffement
donc on a plusieurs le permafrost qu'ils
font
libère du méthane qui est encore plus
pernicieux que donc on a des effets auto
amplificateur qui font que on peut
regarder la montre encore longtemps mais
si les scientifiques si quinze mille
scientifiques ont lancé un cri d'alarmé
en décembre dernier de 180 pays c'est
quand même qu'il faut agir il faut agir
il faut agir vite
donc tout le monde tout le monde en
parle mais le défi le défi est immense
en fait si on sait que et là je crois
que le manifeste et les différentes
propositions voix ventre et beaucoup
plus en détail que moi là dessus mais on
sait sur où il faut agir
il ya des chiffrages il ya beaucoup de
chiffrage alors par exemple le patronat
allemand dit ok on est d'accord on peut
y aller mais pour arriver à 80 % de
diminution en 2001 2050 c'est 1500
milliards d'euros à mettre sur la table
si on veut passer de 80 % à 20 % à 100 %
faut encore rajouter 2300 milliards
donc les chiffres sont tous lourd là on
voulait vous les connaissez l'union
européenne la cour des comptes
européenne estime qu'il faut investir
chaque année 1000 115 milliards mills 1
15 milliard chaque année la banque
mondiale tous les chiffres convergent
vers la banque mondiale parle de 90
milliards sur 15 ans il son chef
économiste parler des 2 % du pib
la laitue delà des mails au fce chiffre
entre 1 9 et 2 7%
je crois que les chiffres que vous allez
présenter sont exactement vous êtes
entre 2 et 3% à 6 du pib
voilà donc c'est des chiffres
impressionnants qui sont il ya des
choses qui bougent actuellement il ya
beaucoup d'initiatives la finance verte
avance bien il ya plein de choses qui se
passent mais on est dans un rapport de
dimensions qui restent
malheureusement décourageant s'il n'ya
pas d'initiatives s'il n'y a pas un
sursaut est une évolution là dedans
alors en même temps les chiffres qui
apparaissent comme des chiffres de
dépenses c'est c'est un nouveau modèle
économique c'est une semaine ce n'est
pas du gaspillage c'est une c'est aussi
une relance de l'économie c'est aussi
une relance citoyenne andy ram et
l'ademe évalue entre jusqu'à 900 mille
créations d'emplois et je pense que
voulez vous créer aussi les tous et tous
et tous ces chantiers sont vertueux en
création d'emplois
maintenant le constat tout le monde ne
partage que faire alors déjà hier la
hotoie m
elle m'a mentionné que des chantiers
énormes l'humanité c'est en gérer de
temps en temps il ya deux temps en temps
il ya des sceaux historique il ya des
moments où il ya quelque chose de
magique qui se passe et où un kennedy
peut dire qu'en ces temps on va aller
sur la lune et le fer avec 400 mille
créations d'emplois une rousse veulent
peut lancer à victory programme et en
quelques années on dirait normalement
mais c'est pas possible c'est impossible
et on trouverait des tas de raisons mais
les choses se font même quand on a lancé
l'école l'école l'instruction
obligatoire en france c'était sur le
plan logistique
c'était un chantier absolument
incroyable de construction d'écoles de
formation etc
donc quand on veut si on veut s'il ya un
sursaut européen pourquoi pas alors les
deux propositions majeures qui sont au
coeur du bouquin et du pacte ont été il
ya une c1 livre passionnant que je que
je vous recommande comme j'ai pas mener
de flyers je vous recommande le bouquin
ou le ou le site à la préface et de
nicolas hulot la postface et de philippe
maystadt qui est le président honoraire
de l'abbaye et qui valide les deux
propositions essentielles qui sont au
coeur qui sont au coeur du pacte pour le
financement et que je vais vous
présenter rapidement donc il s'agit des
dans un premier temps d'accroître le
flux de financement de flécher la
finance vers le financement à taux zéro
des projets nécessaires je parle des
projets qui trouve qu'ils peuvent
trouver leur rentabilité qui peuvent se
financer par des schémas classiques mais
il s'agit de flécher de manière
considérable la finance dans ce champ là
je pars je veux un constat de je suis
tombé sur la présentation de francs
stratégie est en fait j'étais surpris de
voir à quel point
et quand elle correspond et rejoignez le
constat que l'on fait au départ qui est
que la finance les fonds et les
financements existent ils existent ils
sont même très présents différents
différents chiffres et on va juste
focaliser sur le dernier donc je ne
parle pas des paradis fiscaux je parle
pas des de ce qu'on continue à aller de
ce qu'ils continuent à aller vers les
énergies fossiles qui est énorme mais si
l'on parle de la création monétaire au
niveau européen
on a été surpris tout le monde a été
surpris qu'en 2014
la bce a lancé son démarré son programme
de quantitative easing ça aussi on
aurait pu dire c'est impossible
jamais les allemands n'accepteront ça
c'est fait ça c'est fait et ça et ça
continue ça a continué pendant ses 2300
milliards 2003 de 1300 milliards qui ont
été créés en trois ans avec quelquefois
des pics jusqu'à 200 230 milliards créés
en une journée à tour négatif injectés
dans l'économie
et ce qui est donc cet argent existe est
allé vers les banques
il se trouve que pour différentes
raisons là l'augmentation de financement
de l'économie réelle dans la même
période de temps n'est que de 230
milliards c'est à dire que ces fonds
sont injectées mais pour l'instant on
n'arrive pas les fléchés vers l'économie
réelle
et là il semble que l'on puisse avoir un
sujet où à la fois ce problème de
gestion financière et de
et de 2500 milliards là tout le détail
des créations pendant cette période là
et l'évolution des prêts au secteur
privé
comparé à cette création de liquidités
émises par l'ambitieux donc les
financements pourraient en pressant mais
bien entendu sa soeur tad état de
difficultés on pressent que les finances
pour être fléché
parce qu'actuellement effectivement ça
va dans le vert les marchés vers des
marchés dérivés des marchés financiers
au point qu' il y a c'est un des sujets
de ce livre qu'il ya aussi un risque de
nouvelle crise financière dont on n'est
pas à l'abri et donc que peut-on faire
en matière climatique
donc il n'est pas question de toucher à
la bce mais on peut imaginer que la
banque européenne d'investissement ou
une filiale à créer de la banque
européenne d'investissement pourraient
jouer un rôle de coordination de
management de ces fonds de fonds
croissant allant vers les pays pour
fournir les fameux 2 % de droits de
tirage dans chaque pays
donc l'idée est de n'ont pas touché le
bestiau statutairement impossible mais
soin de modifier le rôle de la berri
soin de lui permettre de créer une
filiale spécialisée développement
durable pour assurer ce fléchage des de
financement vert pour jouer jouer ce
rôle de véritable plan marshall en fait
pour reprendre un autre événement
historique qui a qui a pu être possible
donc comment faire pour que chaque année
pendant 30 ans pendant ces trente années
chaque pays européens puissent
bénéficier de 2 % de financement à taux
zéro pour l'injecter dans les projets
labellisés est fléché
ça ferait 45 milliards pour la france ça
ferait 60 milliards pour l'allemagne ça
ferait 16 milliards pour la pologne
chacun de ces pays pouvant gérer ses
propres problèmes avec sa propre logique
on peut imaginer que les polonais les
allemands on trouverait des financements
pour résoudre des problèmes de charbon
nous allons nous avons d'autres
problèmes donc droit de tirage via sept
banques européennes de chaque pays à
hauteur de 2%
première partie du première partie du
projet contenues dans le pacte climat
deuxième sujet on peut imaginer que ces
financements sous forme de prêt ne
suffisent pas parce que tous les projets
ne trouve pas forcément une rentabilité
surtout avec les prix carbone tels
qu'ils sont à court terme ne trouve pas
forcément une rentabilité immédiate donc
pour ces projets là pour les un certain
nombre de projets plus lourds plomb à
rentabilité plus longue
un des subsides des subventions sont
nécessaires et pourrait être gérés dans
le cadre du budget européen donc
emmanuel macron pour lequel madonna
qu'on milite depuis quelques mois et
vient d'obtenir des résultats vient
d'obtenir une avancée avec un gala
merkel en début de semaine donc ce
budget européen qui pourrait débloquer
et mac on parle depuis a parlé de 40%
d'un budget européen qui devrait
climatique il ya quelques mois on peut
imaginer de chercher 100 milliards
d'euros et on va faire une proposition
pour dire où les trouver pour financer
le climat en sachant qui a tout de suite
une première ligne dont il faut reparler
c'est suite à copenhague à la cop15 les
pays les pays se sont engagés à financer
le développement
la transition climatique dans les pays
du sud et ce n'est que justice
à partir de 2020 2020 c'est après demain
il va falloir le compte à rebours est
engagé comment fait-on pour remplir cet
engagement qui est de 100 milliards au
niveau mondial et pour lequel l'europe
pourrait jouer sa part à hauteur de 40
milliards annuels
40 milliards à trouver 50 milliards qui
pourrait co financer les chantiers à
rentabilité un retour sur investissement
plus doute plus lointain plus difficile
en de manière à donner un coup de pouce
je vais revenir et 10 milliards pour
muscler recherche et innovation donc en
fait on rejoint au niveau du haut niveau
de la manière dont des différentes
solutions alors en fait il n'y a pas de
solution unique donc on vous on insiste
sur quelques pistes aujourd'hui mais
bien entendu c'est un ensemble c'est un
ensemble de solutions qui sort qui
devraient être tenus mais mario monti
privé insiste sur la faisais la
possibilité d'un impôt européen sur le
bénéfice il s'agit de doter l'europe
d'un budget maintenant la question c'est
où le prendre se passe sur les citoyens
pas sur les entreprises
ou peut-être les entreprises du
numérique qu'un parent mais sur les
résultats des entreprises
en sachant que depuis des années le
dumping
il ya un certain dans ping entre les
pays européens qui fait dégringoler le
taux d'imposition sur les bénéfices
alors que pendant ces années s'est
terminé alors que aujourd'hui mais
pendant toutes ces années le taux
d'imposition sur les bénéfices américain
est resté étonnamment stable il est
resté impôt fédéral plus impôts des
états étaient largement nous étions en
phase dans les années 90 et les
européens ont pendant toutes ces années
c'est étaient les grands étaient bien
plus libéraux sur ce point que bon c'est
tromper descendu à 20 il y aura un
différentiel avec les avec les avec les
la position des états donc on sera
autour de 24 il ya encore de lavage la
possible l'idée d'ajouter 5 % au niveau
de chaque pays européen n'est pas à
exclure
et c'est une solution pour proposer un
budget européen
donc l'idée de ces 5 % c'est d'abord de
remettre cet argent dans l'économie
réelle
on sait que les on sait qu'une partie
importante des profits et distribuer la
part distribuée ces dernières années est
croissante
il ya moyen de remettre cet argent dans
l'économie réelle et il ya moyen de
donner un signal fort et un déclic pour
financer les projets est il financé de
manière durable aux côtés des prêts à
taux zéro donc si on prend l'exemple de
chantier du type par exemple rénovation
rénovation de bâtiments on peut imaginer
un schéma comme aujourd'hui et des
nationalement financés par des prêts est
là avec un coup de pouce européen en
plus tout ceci devant être établi que ce
que ce soit les prêts à taux zéro ou ce
mécanisme de subvention devant être
inscrits avec une grande stabilité dans
la durée on sait que sur tous ces
problèmes que ce soit on peut se
rappeler du photos de ce qui s'est passé
sur le photovoltaïque où on pourrait
évoquer la rénovation des logements ce1
d un des points bloquants
c'est l'incertitude si si les acteurs ne
peuvent pas se projeter à 5-6 ans par
exemple
rien rien n'évolue où les négawatts avec
l'association doremi par exemple propose
quelque chose d'assez brillant sur le
sur la formation la labellisation des
projets de rénovation mais ce type de
projet ne peut se faire que s'il y a une
visibilité et une stabilité sur
plusieurs années voilà un exemple de
finances possibilités de financement de
mme x voilà donc si la cie les factures
de ce type de d'opérations qui prennent
ovation sont financées de manière
globale comme cela pourquoi ne pas
évoluer vers une directivité plus grande
et rendent obligatoire des travaux qui
trouveraient un tel financement création
d'emplois je reprendrai les chiffres
dont les dégâts
imaginez les gains sur les ménages les
gares sur les diminutions d'importation
et c'est bien pour terminer il s'agit
pas de privilégier une ou deux solutions
si c'est un ensemble bien entendu il
faut parler aussi des prix du carbone
mais en sachant que c'est plus délicat
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne en ce moment
bien entendu il faut développer la
finance verte labellisé fléché bien
entendu il faut parler de taxe sur les
transactions financières définir de
nouveaux standards et mobiliser les
citoyens dans un moment où l'europe
souffre énormément de doutes et de
populisme jeu le projet en question peut
être aussi l'occasion de répondre à une
crise démocratique
voilà donc le concrètement il ya
quelques mois pour nous qui sont très
importants devant nous le pacte finances
climat s'attache à la rédaction d'un
projet d'une proposition de traiter et
miguel-angel moratinos et olivier de
schutter sur anima
une réflexion avec différents des gens
de différents pays donc les espagnols
viennent de rejoindre en force
le pacte dans plusieurs pays européens
il ya des personnes qui travaillent là
dessus il y a quelques mois devant nous
un gala merkel et emmanuel macron ont
décidé de relancer l'europe et d'ouvrir
un débat dans les dans les mois qui
viennent nous allons avoir le le débat
si les échanges de la réflexion
citoyenne animé par le gouvernement dans
les prochains mois ensuite en octobre
rapport spécial du giec et rapport
climat onu et en décembre à la fois la
coop 24 et immédiatement derrière le
sommet européen
c'est dans cette perspective que
vraiment on encourage on vous encourage
tous si ce n'est pas encore fait à vous
associer au manifeste et au pacte parce
que c'est vraiment pas le moment de
baisser les bras
je vous remercie beaucoup je vais passer
immédiatement la parole à jean-marc
jancovici qui est le quai le président
du chiffre project et jean marc est ce
que tu peux expliquer quelle était la
philosophie des propositions qu'on
attachait de mettre sur la table durant
la dure lacombe la campagne
présidentielle je peux pas chanter que
amélie de montchanin madame la députée
de nous quitter à 20h pétantes s'il me
semble bien donc voilà donc si je
pouvais durant cinq minutes ça serait
bien ce serait formidable
alors je vais commencer par un prérequis
qui peut vous paraître un peu un peu
stratosphérique mais en fait auxquels je
crois profondément
je pense que tout le monde se fout du
climat et que on avancera sur ce sujet
qu'à partir du moment où c'est un coût
bénéfice d'un problème de court terme
qu'on a à traiter par ailleurs ce que je
vois depuis que je m'occupe de ce
problème dans le monde économique
c'est que personne ne fait quoi que ce
soit pour le climat au détriment du
court terme
absolument personne et pas plus les
politiques français que les politiques
européens ne feront ça
donc on avancera sur la question du
climat à partir du moment où ça
deviendra un kobe néfice le problème de
court terme qu'on a besoin de traiter
par ailleurs c'est quoi les problèmes de
aujourd'hui on apprenne d'emploi qui
nourrit directement la question
populiste on a un problème de projets
européens
l'europe s'est gentiment fourvoyé en
passant d'un objectif commun à une mise
en commun de moyens donc aujourd'hui le
projet de l'europe c'est de faire à
marcher je m'en fous de marché ce que
j'ai envie de savoir c'est si on va
vivre en paix ou pas et si on va faire
des trucs ensemble ou pas savoir que
dans l'article 3 du projet constitue un
rejet de la constitution européenne on
dit quoi faire un projet de marché ou
est très bien et on a donc il faut qu'on
trouve du sens si on trouve qu'il faut
qu'on retrouve le envie de faire des
choses ensemble et il faut que ces
affaires-là résiste à des choses qui
vont nous arriver de toute façon qu'ils
sont des divergences de points de vue
est-ce qu'il y en aura toujours et qui
sont des crises économiques dont la
prochaine se profile à l'horizon
g poker l'opinion du crédit agricole sur
la question aller n'importe quoi entre
six mois et 18 mois on va dire on va
commencer à rentrer en 2019 je pense
dans l'année de tous les dangers
et le fait d'avoir un projet qui
s'incarne dans quelque chose qui se
nomme et qui est pas juste des
indicateurs économiques
c'est à l'évidence un moyen d'être
résilient quand on sait que l'économie
va être un peu secoué alors c'est là
qu'on en vient à la question du climat
c'est que de s'attaquer à la question de
la décarbonation de l'économie
koch ces cases là où potentiellement
coach sait qu'à cela
alors sacoche ces cases là parce qu on
nomme l'objet au lieu de donner les
moyens
dire qu'au lieu de dire on va faire 2 %
de déficit on dit qu'on va faire en
commun exactement comme kennedy a dit on
va aller sur la lune c'est facile
qu'elle ait dit parce que c'était dans
une époque à moyens croissants
donc moi résoudre des problèmes à moyens
croissants je sais faire et n'importe
quel brel sait faire c'est très facile
le problème auquel on est confronté
aujourd'hui c'est de résoudre des
problèmes à moyen des croissants
ça s'est considérablement plus compliqué
donc le parce que les moyens je le redis
mes moyens économiques pour des raisons
énergétiques vont décroître donc le il
faut nommer l'objet donc on peut dire
que c'est ça l'esprit du manifeste dire
qu'on va faire en commun des bâtiments
des trains une agriculture qui est big
horn et comme ceux ci comme cela et
d'autres projets
ça parlera probablement plus aux gens
que de leur dire on va faire 2 % de
déficit
parce que faire rêver quelqu'un avec 2 %
de déficit
bon courage lehoux avec 1 % avec 3 % on
s'en fiche
donc ça peut éventuellement permettre de
refonder un projet européen qui
aujourd'hui est en train de partir en
quenouille et dont la ligne de pente
c'est qu'il va continuer à partir en
quenouille puisqu'on n'est pas d'annoncé
on n'a pas dit qu'on avait envie de
faire ensemble
je rappelle que la fondation du projet
européen c'était de mise en commun des
moyens énergétiques
c'était la ceca et euratom donc on avait
nommé l'objet et on avait nommé ce qu'on
avait envie de faire ensemble
on avait dit pourquoi c'était pour vivre
en paix et le marché était un moyen
accessoires ils étaient relégués à sa
place c'est à dire de moyens accessoires
le manifeste donc je le redis c'est un
moyen de régler un problème d'emploi
c'est qu'il faut nommer ce qu'on va
faire
la difficulté c'est que y'aura pas plus
d'argent pour plus d'emplois pour tout
le monde
on va devoir créer plus d'emplois avec
moins d'argent pour tout le monde donc
ça va être compliqué mais c'est quand
même un moyen de créer de l'emploi
le deuxième moyen c'est que ça permet de
refonder une europe et on refera pas
l'europe en passant par l'intérieur en
passant par la commission je crois pas à
la révolution de l'intérieur pas une
seconde je pense que refonder l'europe
ça veut dire porter un projet qui
s'incarne dans des trucs un peu concrets
et ensuite prendre son bâton de pèlerin
et aller convaincre un par un les pays
que c'est quelque chose qui peut flotter
donc c'est l'oeuvre d'un mandat a minima
exactement comme schumann gaspésie et
leurs copains il avait un projet ils
sont allés prendre leur bâton de pèlerin
ils sont allés parler à tout le monde ça
règle le problème des règles un problème
macroéconomique quand même sympathique
c'est que là tout à l'heure on a cité le
chiffre de 200 et quelques milliards
d'importations ça dépend évidemment
énormément du prix du baril moi la
première fois que j'ai fait ce calcul
c'était en 2010 donc ce chiffre est
beaucoup plus impressionnant est à 5 ou
600 milliards mais en gros l'europe
apporte chaque année quelques centaines
de milliards de combustible fossile donc
un rapide calcul macroéconomique vous
dis qu en face de ça vous avez de quoi
payer la nuitée d'un investissement de
15 milliards d'euros
donc on peut investir plein d'argent en
europe et ce et se financer quelque part
sur les importations éviter à partir du
moment où ces investissements ont
justement pour but de ne pas consommer
d'énergies fossiles a en ce moment on
est en train de faire exactement ce
qu'il faut pas on est en train de
financer de quoi augmenter les
importations européennes pour s'attaquer
à un problème qui n'existe pas je veux
parler du remplacement du nucléaire par
des éoliennes et des panneaux solaires
ça c'est s'attaquer à un problème qui
n'est pas climatique et augmenter les
importations puisque les panneaux
solaires sont fabriqués en chine et que
une partie des nacelles d'éoliennes
maintenant sont fabriqués en chine aussi
donc quand on fait ça on augmente les
importations pour ne pas résoudre le
problème du co2 ont détruit de l'emploi
pour ne pas résoudre le problème du co2
et ça nous a quand même coûté en europe
à date huit ou neuf cents milliards
voilà je suis pas sûr qu'ils suffisent
d'investir pour résoudre le problème
on vient d'en rajouter 25 en france du
reste avec les éoliennes offshore qui
vont produire exactement le même mais
les mêmes conséquences c'est-à-dire
détruire de l'emploi macroéconomique
mans pour ne pas résoudre le problème
donc il faut investir mais dans le
second secteur et le le dernier
problèmes qu'on a dans dans cette
affaire c'est qu'il faut passer la
volatilité de la démocratie puisque on
change de dirigeants tous les cinq ans
et que en démocratie comme vous le savez
le dirigeant est pas vraiment à
dirigeants c'est plutôt un exécuteur
tafas et intermédiaire entre un
dirigeant et un exécuteur testamentaire
c'est à dire qu'il a un programme
il dit qu'il va le mettre en oeuvre donc
il devient exécuteurs testamentaires
il est aussi dirigeant parce qu'il a des
pouvoirs réels et donc il est dans un
rôle qui est intermédiaire entre les
deux et ce rôle et volatil car quand on
change le représentant on change une
partie de ce qu'il va mettre en oeuvre
or les sujets dont on va parler
maintenant rénover le logement changer
le système énergétique changer les
modèles agricoles etc
le pas de temps ces deux générations au
bas mot parce que ça suppose de changer
les schémas culturels parce que et c'est
donc si vous changez de boussole tous
les cinq ans vous êtes sûrs d'aller
nulle part absolument alors une fois
qu'ils disent à ce qu'on avait mis sur
la table avant les élections
présidentielles étaient censés comme je
le redis coché ces cases c'est à dire
proposer un projet pour recommencer à
parler d'europe mais autour de projets
pas autour de mesures
c'était un projet qui était ce qu'on
peut faire de mieux sur le plan
macroéconomique en supprimant le plus
possible des importations de
combustibles fossiles
c'est un projet qui permet de dire où on
va avoir besoin de monde puisque on
nomme les filières en disant on va avoir
besoin de faire des choses dans tel
domaine tel domaine tel domaine et elle
domaine donc on sait qu'on a besoin de
maçons et pas de gens pour faire d'un
tas de l'intelligence artificielle ça
tombe mal parce qu'en ce moment ce n'est
pas la mode mais c'était
enfin lire les plus j'ai pas vu monsieur
macro avec une truelle je les ai vus
avec des lunettes virtuel donc oui je
suis un peu taquin c'est mon rôle
et enfin et les instituteurs le retard
mais continue à dire ado grèce si tu es
nul tu feras plombier et si tu es bon tu
iras faire de l'intelligence
artificielle chez google donc donc on en
reste aujourd'hui quand même dans un
discours qui n'est pas exactement adapté
à ce dont on va avoir besoin demain et
on a eu un raisonnement bête et méchant
de règle de trois c'est à dire qu'on a
dit si le projet devient de décarbonés
l'économie alors je rappelle aussi un
truc important c'est que le carbone
c'est l'énergie et l'énergie c'est les
flux physiques donc avoir une lecture
carbone de l'économie c'est avoir une
lecture de mise en cohérence des flux
physiques et comme vous trichez pas avec
la physique
de toute façon les flux physiques vont
se mettre en cohérence
si vous essayez si vous n'essayez pas de
le faire de manière délibérée ils le
feront de toute façon spontanément et
donc si vous avez des programmes
politiques qui suppose de violer la mise
en cohérence des flux physiques
programme politique fera faillite
c'est absolument certain et j'invite
tous les gens qui ont quelque en trois
sous d'économies dans cette salle a
parié contre tout programme politique
qui suppose de violer les lois de la
physique par un vote à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes sûr de gagner de
l'argent
si vous trouvez une contrepartie et on
essaye souvent et pas qu'en france je
veux dire dans tous les pays européens
donc une fois que j'ai dit ça c'était
quoi le programme concret qu'on
proposait on a regardé dans chacun des
secteurs qu'elle était la première
mesure à mettre en oeuvre si on voulait
être sérieux sur la question de la
décarbonation de l'économie et on a
regardé les investissements qu'il
fallait mettre en face mais les
investissements dans un certain nombre
de cas de figure c'est pas des
investissements qui vont tomber du ciel
c'est des investissements qui vont
sortir de la poche des gens que vous
êtes et que je suis parce qu'une partie
de ces investissements vont correspondre
à des obligations
je prends l'exemple du contrôle
technique des voitures on vous dit allez
allez passer les contrôles techniques et
puis si votre voiture elle n'est pas
conforme vous allez faire des travaux
sur vos doigts jordan n'a jamais dit les
tables ou pays les travaux que vous
voulez payer de votre poche
donc là par exemple dans le bâtiment
l'état n'aura pas les poches assez
profondes pour payer les travaux de mise
en conformité chez tout le monde
donc il faut un obligé de évidemment
créer des facilités pour que ça soit le
plus indolore possible pour les ménages
pays de filet si les ménages
e-bay exactement comme quand on vous
oblige à ravaler les copropriétés
parisienne on vous dit pas c'est la
municipalité qui va payer pour vous vous
obliger à le faire vous payez point quoi
donc un certain nombre de domaines dans
lesquels le sujet n'est pas
l'investissement il est le courage
politique d'obliger à faire ça n'a
strictement rien à voir c'est pas un
problème d'investissement c'est juste un
problème de ranger les problèmes dans
l'ordre pardon pour la répétition est
par ailleurs d'avoir le courage de faire
la pédagogie de l'obligation c'est à
dire de dire ben là il ya des trucs
auxquels on va pas échapper de toute
façon donc autant s'y attaquer de la
manière la plus intelligente possible
on manque en ce moment cruellement dans
la sphère politique je parle pas pour
moi voisine de gauche parle d'un
panorama général de ce que j'ai observé
depuis 18 ans un d'une compréhension du
problème de a fortiori d'une pédagogie
du problème et 3 de la capacité à ranger
les éléments de solution au problème
dans le bon ordre
voilà c'est compliqué de faire de la
pédagogie sont apprennent qu'on n'a pas
compris soi même alors une fois que j'ai
une fois que j'ai que j'ai dit ça donc
les mesures auxquelles on a dit qu'on
s'attaquait c'est les bâtiments c'est
25% des émissions donc offert quelque
chose sur le parc existant
but du jeu c'est pas de normaliser neuf
on s'en fou d'une offre puisque c'est un
accroissement du parc existant
ce qui compte c'est par ketty ce temps
là il ya un deuxième sujet qui concerne
les les transports il ya un troisième
sujet qui concerne l'électricité en fait
sept premiers l'électricité au charbon
c'est un quart des émissions européennes
donc il faut fermer les centrales à
charbon soit dit en passant il n'y a
aucune chance aucune d'atteindre même
pas deux mais trois degrés de
réchauffement dans le monde si on ne
ferait-on pas la totalité des centrales
à charbon dans le monde dans les 30 à 40
ans qui viennent alors la totalité des
centrales à charbon dans le monde pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais entendu prononcer
chiffres ces 2010 aouate 2002 un peu
plus maintenant 2100 en 2002 sans la
chine jusqu'en fin 2016 en rajoutait 40
tous les ans c'est à dire que tous les
ans ils rajoutaient les deux tiers de
notre parc nucléaire qui nous excite en
centrale à charbon non obstant le fait
que par ailleurs on explique qu'ils
mettent pleins d owlient est donc le le
sujet aujourd'hui dans le monde sur le
charbon qui fait 20% des émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre c'est
de supprimer la totalité des centrales à
charbon
on fait ça on a une petite chance de
limiter le réchauffement climatique ont
fait pas ça on n'a juste pas sérieux
après remplacé par ce que vous voulez
s'il ya des gens qui pensent qu'ils vont
y arriver avec juste des éoliennes et du
stockage très bien qu'ils essayent
qu'ils le fassent et qu'ils aillent
jusqu'au bout puis s'il n'y arrive pas
on leur colle une prune ça doit être ça
le projet européen aussi ils le font ils
disent qu'ils vont le faire ils le font
parce qu'un autre truc il faut avoir le
courage de dire c'est qu'en permet une
obligation il faut à la fois mettre
éventuellement des facilités pour la
remplir mais une sanction si on la
remplit pas sinon c'est pas une
obligation c'est une incitation d'accord
si vous dites à vos enfants je vous
oblige à aller ou à laver les mains
avant d'aller à la table c'est vous leur
donnez rien à manger tant qu'ils n'ont
pas fait sinon c'est une incitation donc
dans les transports il ya un sujet qui
est de baisser la consommation des
véhicules là ça passe essentiellement
par l'obligation c'est pas un problème
d'investissement
si on vous oblige à acheter des petites
voitures qui consomment peu injuste on
vous oblige absolument pas un problème
de capacité d'investissement il y avait
un sujet en ce qui concerne les
transports alors là il retombe de
nouveau sur un sujet d'investissements
si on veut remplacer les avions parlé
train pour dire les choses oui j'ai fini
en 15 secondes
il ya un sujet de il ya un sujet de
financement des infrastructures
il ya un sujet agricole et forestier là
qui est à la fois un sujet de fléchage
des financements existants un sujet
éventuellement de nouveaux
investissements parce que la question du
foncier dans le domaine agricole est
quand même une question majeure et mais
aussi une question d'obligation
on peut on peut obliger à faire et enfin
dans les dents le dernier sujet il ya
quelque chose d'un peu transversale
quand on met tout ça bout à bout on
parle effectivement de 2 à 3% du pib
européen tous les ans mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on laisse le reste tranquille il
faut contraindre les 97% du pib qui
reste parce que sinon c'est 97% la font
exactement ce qu'ils veulent échappe et
vous avez juste un transfert la dernière
chose qu'il faut faire c'est avoir une
métrique et alors aujourd'hui la
métrique
elle est absolument pas au point et je
vais finir par une anecdote d'actualité
vous êtes peut-être au sujet au courant
par donc la commission vient de créer un
groupe d'experts pour parler de la
taxonomie des investissements verts je
vois venir gros comme une maison que il
va y avoir une grande entreprise de
greenwashing derrière ce truc là c'est à
dire qu'on va faire passer comme vers
tout un tas de trucs qui n'ont rien à y
faire
je vous donne un exemple la voiture
électrique je suis sûr qu'elle sera
verte quel que soit le pays ou à les
financer
alors que vous faites une voiture
électrique en pologne c'est plus de co2
et plus de particules qu'en france que
une voiture à diesel
donc il va y avoir un vrai sujet de
metric et là le diable est dans les
détails et aujourd'hui aussi
l'obligation de mesurer correctement ce
genre de truc n'est absolument pas
rentré dans les moeurs
aujourd'hui quand une société fait
absolument n'importe quoi au niveau des
chiffres qu'elle communique sur ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre elle
de risque strictement rien donc le fond
de mon discours c'est évidemment qu'on
peut faire la seule chose que je dis de
manière très provocante c'est faut en
avoir envie au point qu on accepte
l'obligation de faire qui va avec
voilà c'est ça le sujet merci je n'a je
passe toute la parole à un rally de
montchanin et qui connaît
il connaît bien ses enjeux retrait vos
réactions par rapport aux démarches
comporte et puis expliquez nous quelle
est la démarche du gouvernement et d'une
majorité parlementaire sur ce sujet
bonsoir je le tiens juste à dire que je
ne m'exprime pas au nom du gouvernement
je n'incarne pas la république et
sûrement pas la réponse enfin pas la
république en marche et si on me parle
la république
je vais vous parler de ce qui a fait ma
vie jusque avant d'être député il ya un
an
savoir d'avoir travaillé dans deux
moments je pense qu'ils sont extrêmement
pertinent pour notre sujet du jour qui
était la task force pour le je voudrais
en anglais united financial disclosure
c'était le groupe de travail de
bloomberg
avec tous les banquiers centraux lancée
après la coop 21 pour que justement les
entreprises quelles qu'elles soient soit
dans une obligation de faire beaucoup de
choses différentes et je vais revenir et
puis la dernière chose que j'ai faite
avant de rentrer en campagne jusqu'au 10
mai 2010 est au soir c'était de tenir la
plume du rapport d'experts de haut
niveau sur la finance durable de la
commission européenne donc c'est de là
que je vous parle c'est important je
pense à ces les choses ensuite qu'ils
sont toujours très forte pour moi et qui
du coup alimente beaucoup d échanges que
j'ai pu avoir avec les uns et les autres
et qui j'espère je dirais guyane un
petit peu des discussions nous avons
dans notre majorité et avec la
république avec n'est pas en marge d'air
en vous écoutant ça tombe bien l'un et
l'autre finalement vous fait ma
transition
ma conviction profonde bien sûr que
c'est une question d'argent mais c'est
avant tout une question pas forcément
d'argent nouveau
c'est de l'argent qui aujourd'hui
quelques chiffres on investit 6 tribu en
six mille milliards de dollars par an
dans le monde
donc le sujet c'est pour moi pas d'aller
voir comment on peut trouver des
milliers d'ennemis et milliards les
milliers mais là ils sont ils en
existent et sont déjà investis pour moi
le sujet c'est comment ces milliers de
milliards qui sont investis ces les
fameux 97% de mon voisin au bout de la
table
comment ces investissements existants
deviennent des investissements
contributifs à la transition qu'on doit
faire
bien sûr il ya un pouillème par rapport
à celle ci me lumière de nouveaux
investissements qu'il faut faire et à
clef de lecture c'est que ce qu'on
appelle la finance verte et c'est pour
ça que c'est mon grand combat c'est que
trop pour trop souvent elle ne
s'intéresse qu'aux nouveaux
investissements que ces fameux 2%
le combat pour moi et ça que je fais
depuis maintenant quatre ans dans ma vie
d'avant et dans la mienne maintenant
c'est de bien faire comprendre que on
peut bien sûr s'occuper des 2% nouveau
et il faut qu'on s'en occupe il ya plein
de gens qui sont donc il ya eu plein
juncker était un plan de l'abbaye très
proche de ce que vous proposez quand on
regarde un peu honnêtement ce qui s'est
passé ça peut être un prof d'argent cet
aprem de projets qu'on avait du mal à
faire arriver les problèmes là
typiquement moi et mon sujet c'est à
court terme
l'argent il y en a plein plein plein il
ya 1600 milliards sur l'assurance vie
des français il ya 400 milliards sur les
comptes courants des français dans
allouer 400 milliards vous ne le dites
il faut aussi ça donc le problème pour
moi n'est pas un problème de me trouver
de l'argent c'est sûrement pas un
problème allait augmenter les impôts
juste pour vous une idée les chiffres
qui vous ont été présentés sur les taux
d'imposition il a annoncé en même temps
que le budget la zone euro cette semaine
par angela merkel macroule un projet qui
s'appelle axis qui est une consolidation
de la base dans la peau sociétés l'impôt
au seul de la société pour le combat
pour moi c'est pas un problème de
taussat brême de base il ya des trous
dedans et trop qui sont en in luxembourg
et des trous qui sont en irlande y ait
des trous qui sont en france
la niche copé quand elle était votée
bonne idée on pensait que ça coûterait
200 millions ça a coûté 22 milliards sur
trois ans donc on sait de nous mêmes
faire des gros trous des p'tits trous ça
dépend si on aime les chansons du métro
donc le sujet pour moi c'est pas de
trouver vraiment j'insiste pour moi a
vraiment mon urgence c'est pas de créer
de l'argent ce n'est pas de trouver de
l'argent c'est même pas d'aller voir la
bce pour moi c'est comment sur les flux
d'investissement actuel sur les 6000
milliards qui sont investis dans le
monde on en fait des investissements qui
sont contributifs à la transition
ce qui veut dire deux choses c'est qu'il
faut qu'on ait un cadre où effectivement
il ya une forme d'obligation
ce cadre là c'est le cadre que donc deux
projets dont j'aimerais vous parler on
va essayer de faire des choses quand
bloomberg alors blumert sa norme de
chiffres ça donne de donner son métier
c'est de communiquer ce que font les
entreprises à travers des myriades de
chief qui ne pas être des gens qui font
ensuite monter ou baisser les cours à la
bourse
une conviction qu'il a eu c'est à dire
pourquoi moi je ne deviens pas l'outil
bloomberg qui communique aussi des
choses sur ce que les entreprises
produisent qu'il n'est pas financier
mais qui est ce qui m dans l'atmosphère
au début son projet c'est à dire je vais
être la base d'informations sur combien
chaque entreprise maîtres co2 dans le
monde
sauf que si vous faites ça en fait vous
êtes en train de faire une photo de
temps à dire aujourd'hui
saint gobain air liquide ce qu'on voudra
dans le monde
air france émet x tonnes de co2 ce co2
émis aujourd'hui c'est le fruit des
investissements et des choix
stratégiques du passé si vous êtes air
liquide vous émettez tous les jours ce
que votre usine vous mêmes qu'elles
aimaient ce que vous avez décidé en
faisant vos choix technologiques hier
c'est la conséquence du passé
le sujet pour nous c'est de rentrer dans
le film passer de la photo au film
qu'est-ce qu'on veut que les entreprises
demain produisent et face et ça veut
donc dire que les entreprises
il faut bien sûr les interroger sur
combien les émettre de co2 aujourd'hui
mais il faut surtout les interroger sur
qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire dans cinq
dix vingt trente ans pas juste comment
vous allez produire mais surtout
qu'est-ce que vous allez vendre parce
que on peut demander à bmw de nous faire
des usines supergreen d'avoir des
poubelles de recyclage dans chacun de
ces bureaux d'avoir de l'eau en
bouteille en verre d'avoir moins de
papier utilisé ça on peut s'appelle la
stratégie e es rsg toutes les
entreprises sont de plus en plus verte
mais si bmw continue dans 30 ans de se
projeter en imaginant vente des voitures
thermiques et bien je peux vous dire que
on n'aura pas fait le début du quart du
chemin est donc la stratégie de seconde
de travail du g20
dire vous entreprise vous devez dire à
vos actionnaires non seulement ce que
vous émettez en co2 aujourd'hui et de
manière fiable mesurable quantifiable
opposable est ce que vous voulez mais
vous devez surtout leur dire qu est ce
que vous imaginez vendre comme produit
demain qu'ils soient cohérents avec un
monde zéro carbone et donc ça veut dire
expliquez-nous est-ce que vous changez
votre pote mix quand vous avez des
grands acteurs miniers qui vous disent
moi aujourd'hui je fais 80 % du chiffre
d'affaires sur le charbon en 2005 ans
j'en ferai deux ça ça s'appelle une
stratégie de transition et ensuite vous
actionnaires vous allez suivre chaque
jour
le fait de s que et prend bien des
décisions qui vont l'amener de passer de
80 à 2 donc on au nom de quelle
contrainte elle ferait ça alors
aujourd'hui en france
l'article 173 qui est un article il n'y
a pas de sanction sauf qu'aujourd'hui la
mf peut considérer qu'on les regarde
votre rapport annuel
j'en rêve qui est qui qui épingle une
boîte j'ai été les voir pour leur
demander s'ils pouvaient faire ça ils
m'ont dit que non quand même pas de
mandrake quoi ya enfin il ya quand même
si vous regardez tous les assureurs qui
sont quand même les plus grands les
grands porteurs d'actifs en du repas les
managers d'actifs et les propriétaires
d'actifs
y'a pas même un trillion d'actifs qui
font du l'article 173 quelque chose qui
est compatible avec un scénario zéro
carbone vous avez un ce nombre en fait
c'est moi les entreprises d'aujourd'hui
qui sont l'aiguillon c'est plus les gens
qui portent leur titre et là dessus vous
avez objectivement des choses que tu vas
pas dire que tout est fait mais je
trouve que cette démarche qui consiste à
moins que les entreprises fassent à
qu'est ce que vous vendez qu'est ce que
vous faites et surtout que vous
communiquer aux actionnaires
le vrai risque vous portez total je
prends des exemples je sais pas si vous
travaillez certains chez total mais
total on verra ce que ça donne mais
quand il annonce
voilà moi j'ai une ambition de faire x
plus de puissance solaire altère x
gigawatts ou l'x mégawatts dont tant
d'années ça devient opposable
l'actionnaire qui porte sa il peu comme
quand il regarde tous les chiffres
financiers
ça c'est très important et je pense que
c'est une démarche qui va justement dans
l'idée qu'on veut convertir les 97%
investissements d'aujourd'hui
l'autre chose dont je vous parlais c'est
le cadre européen
la fameuse fameux groupe d'experts de
haut niveau c'est quelque chose qui moi
je suis très près effectivement une des
choses que ça a permis de créer c'est ce
groupe sur qu'est-ce qui est ce qui est
vert qu'est ce qu'il n'est pas mais
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'était la première fois que la
commission européenne prenez un pas de
recul et se disait qu'il y avait un
problème dans leur stratégie
ce qu'on parle d'europe ce soir c'est
que d'un côté vous avez un discours
magnifique c'est l'europe ce drap le
premier continent à zéro carbone du
monde
on a des bilans carbone on est
extrêmement actif à la coop on pousse un
agenda diplomatique
ça c'est ça c'est la commission verte et
puis vous avez la commission qui est la
commission qui produit de la norme qui
produit de la loi qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
la commission qu'on a produit la norme
et la loi et fait de bons des normes
environnementales ans s'est fait
d'énormes sur la pac et c'est surtout
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de normes
financières beaucoup de normes
comptables beaucoup de normes qui en
fait quand même créé le carcan où le
strait jacket comme en anglais dans
laquelle tout système économique évolue
également donné des gens qui sont qui
sont dit c'est bizarre parce qu'en fait
ce qu'on pousse du côté financier ne
permet pas d'atteindre ce qu'on pousse
du côté vert et que donc on peut
continuer à faire ce mouvement là mais a
abandonné jean-claude une game est un
grand écart c'est pas très confortable
donc comment on peut essayer de faire en
sorte que on continue de pousser du côté
vert parce que c'est bien notre ambition
mais que ce qu'on pousse du côté
financier on le change le sera et
jeffrey trajectoire vers le plus en plus
convergents et dans ce rapport on a
parlé de quoi on a parlé du fait
qu'aujourd'hui toute la finance est
relative
aujourd'hui un bon asset manager c'est
celui qui fait 3 2 % de rendement
trimestriel quand le marché était 3,1
quand vous êtes dans cette logique là
d'un point central de référence tout le
monde fait la même chose puisque être
bon c'est être moins pire que la moyenne
donc si vous avez fait un tout petit peu
de mathématiques et bien il vaut mieux
faire comme la moyenne comme ça vous
être sûr de ne pas être différent de la
moyenne
ça veut dire qu'on a tué toute
conviction dans ce système financier
puisque 1 à un gestionnaire d'actifs il
se dit moi j'ai une stratégie sur 20 ans
parce que je gère de l'épargne-retraite
sur 20 ans et donc sur 20 ans ça vaut le
coup d'aller investir dans la rénovation
thermique et les actifs des produits
dérivés maintenant qui se vante sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
ça existe c'est rentable sur 20 ans vous
faites ce choix vous savez que vous
serez rentable parce qu on a prouvé que
c'était rentable
mais si tout le marché contre lequel on
vous compare lui à une stratégie
d'investissement à 6 12 ou 18 mois
vous ne serez jamais considéré comme
performant vous aurez aider la
transition mais vous n'êtes pas
performant donc c'est une première chose
c'est comment on recrée une finance de
conviction on a le droit dans le système
financier de ne pas avoir le même
rendement trimestriel que la moyenne
parce que sinon c'est complètement enfin
c'est dangereux
cette moyenne s'il faut que vous sachiez
c'est qu'elle est con on est con
calculée par rapport à ce qu'on appelle
le benchmark c'est le rendement moyen de
l'actif moyen et l'actif moyen quand
vous regardez les actions c'est le cac
40 c'est le foot c'est le cac 40 et le
poussif surtout le footy ses 35% de
producteurs d'énergie possible donc en
fait tout le monde compare sa
performance des actifs à la performance
de ce qu'ils produisent un produit dont
on veut plus dans 30 ans donc je vous
simplifie mais ça veut dire que un grand
défi pour la régulation financière
c'est de faire deux choses d'abord il
faut qu'on recrée des horizons de temps
qui soit cohérent avec les projets
comportent
si vous avez de l'épargne-retraite à
gérer et bien il faut que vous puissiez
gérait des actifs qui sont cohérents
avec le monde que vous livrerez à ceux
dont vous rendrez l'argent dans 30 ans
40 ans 50 ans donc vous êtes à fond la
transition si vous de les régénérer de
l'argent sur 5 ans soit 8 ans et bien
vous allez investir dans d'autres
projets dans d'autres projets qui eux
ont un rendement à cinq ou huit ans donc
la bataille pour les horizons temps je
voudrais important très très très
schématique c'est ce qu'on fait dans la
loi pacte en france sur
l'épargne-retraite sur euro croissance
qui est de rendre l'assurance vie avec
des horizons tort plus clair et donc
bientôt quand vous irez dans vos banques
dans un an
a priori vos conseillers bancaires pour
vous parler des projets d'investissement
en lien avec la durée pour laquelle vous
voulez investir c'est ça on y travaille
beaucoup il ya un peu de chemin à faire
pour que ça arrive jusqu'à toutes vos
agences bancaires mais l'aiguillon que
nous faisons donc je pouvais pas ne pas
vous en parler longuement mais il ya des
choses qui bougent
l'autre chose qu'il faut faire et je
tenir là dessus on a dit c'est des
horizons temps l'autre chose qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut qu'on accepte
d'avoir des acteurs différents et donc
si je reprends vos de présentation bien
sûr qu'il faut mobiliser beaucoup
d'argent mais il faut ensuite qu'on ait
des gens qui deviennent des spécialistes
certains du charbon d'autres
développements
d'autres de la voiture d'autres etc
et je peux vous dire que l'investisseur
qui va être spécialiste dans la centrale
à charbon
il va pas du tout avoir dans la centrale
le nom charbonné plutôt non carbonées il
va pas du tout avoir le même profil ni
de rendement ni d'horizon temps que
celui qui va se lancer dans la
révolution du transport en ville et donc
c'est extrêmement important
je pense une idée à retenir c'est que le
combat qu'on doit avoir c'est le combat
des convictions
nous avons besoin d'investisseurs non
pas qu'ils se disent je suis un
investisseur vert mais je suis un
investisseur qui a fait un choix et
quand vous me donnez votre argent à
gérer voilà le contrat que je passe avec
vous il est différente de celui du
voisin et c'est tant mieux
et ça c'est un combat de société parce
que si vous arrivez à gagner cette
bataille des convictions sur de quoi on
a besoin pour la transition est bien par
miracle on en arrivera à faire la même
chose pour l'innovation parce que
certains vous vous dire moi je fais la
médecine
moi je fais de l'intelligence
artificielle moi je fais de
l'agriculture locale et c'est la
bataille de l'innovation en général
c'est aussi une bataille de conviction
de différenciation donc ça c'est des
choses qu'il faut qu'on pousse ça al'air
considéré comme ça ça devient très
pratique quand on regarde le droit
financier le droit des marchés
l'information aux épargnants et là on
est sur des sujets où nous politique on
a un défi et schmid a su c'est que on a
beau avoir plein d'idées quand on est en
haut niveau français
ensuite il ya la grande moulinette
européenne qui fait que sous couvert de
créer du consensus
et bien en fait on normalise tout est
donc on en revient à l'uniformité et
donc c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
faire parce qu'on n'a pas besoin la
transition en pologne et en france et je
vais pas bien c'est beaucoup
j'ai envie de vous inviter à un peu
on peut prolonger à prolonger sur ce
thème que les outils économiques
financiers sont en gestation sont en
train de se préparer on le voit on en
est on en est acteur est ce que vous
pensez que c'est susceptible épuisé le
sujet sans que effectivement l'ambition
que vous avez décrite politiques soient
portées portait effectivement et là
c'est votre rôle de tante de la élu de
la république en marche
qui est qui et qui est sollicité ou
est-ce qu et à quel moment on peut
s'attendre à voir en france ou ailleurs
en europe la volonté de bâtir une
stratégie cohérente décarbonation donné
comme comme comme fil conducteur à
l'évolution de la finance mais aussi des
modes de consommation
c'est des mots des mots si je peux faire
une remarque aujourd'hui quand vous
voulez aller voir la direction des
routes où la direction des transports à
l'état avec un projet d'infrastructure
si vous présentez pas une projection de
trafic en hausse
ils vous disent tu sers à rien la ligne
18 sur le plateau de saclay c'est mon
combat
non mais manière générale c'est un
exemple d'une manière générale la ligne
18 sur plateau de saclay par ailleurs ne
remboursera jamais son carbone de départ
on a fait les comptes
vous le dire il faut juste il faut juste
l'abandonner cette ligne sert à rien
donc le bonheur à descendre du plateau
parce que les jets à julia et ronda dans
la pièce qui est un grand spécialiste
doit passer sinon je peux vous dire on a
fait les calculs ça remboursera à la
demande de la température ferroviaire ça
ça ne remboursera jamais son carbone de
départ donc si on veut le faire au motif
du carbone faut pas le faire et il s'est
en fait quand je dis ça c'est
illustratif du fait qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a pas juste un problème dans la
finance en apprennent dans l'arbitrage
de nos priorités c'est à dire qu'on
pense on continue à raisonner avec un
logiciel et qui est le logiciel
économique standard qui est qu'on va
pouvoir conjuguer la décarbonation et
l'expansion économique perpétuelle et la
difficulté de départ de tout le modèle
conceptuel de cette affaire c'est que
les deux ne sont pas compatibles
parce que ce qui a fait l'expansion
économique c'est justement les
combustibles fossiles
c'est le fait que les combustibles
fossiles ont permis de démultiplier par
des milliers le parc de machines sur
terre qui sont celles qui produisent à
notre place donc le pouvoir d'achat
c'est les combustibles fossiles c'est
pas juste les opérateurs pétroliers
c'est cette tape pas cher se livrent pas
cher c'est de n'être pas cher sap hr sap
hr sap hr tout ça c'est des combustibles
fossiles
donc l'idée qu'on va lutter contre les
combustibles fossiles et en même temps
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français c'est un mensonge
l'idée qu'on va pouvoir lutter contre
les combustibles fossiles et augmenter
le pib jusqu'à ce que je touche mon
assurance vie c'est un mensonge
donc en fait de cette invention je pense
aussi à nous mêmes on se raconte des
salades donc la vraie difficulté de
cette affaire là c'est d'accepter l'idée
qu'on va devoir faire des arbitrages
parce qu'on pourra pas tout faire à la
fois dans un monde qui ne sera plus
jamais en expansion et qui en fait est
en train de passer déjà en contraction
si vous regardez les flux physiques en
europe ils ont commencé à se contracter
depuis 2007
regardez le trafic routier des
exploitants d'autoroutes le savent très
bien
les tonnes kilomètres en camion baisse
en europe depuis 2007 la construction
pardon non non non non non les top
chargé tant dans les statistiques juste
on a deux pays trois pays autour de nous
qui sont déjà en décroissance
démographique non non non non non non
c'est européen vous regardez les
statistiques dans tous les pays
européens le trafic routier est passé
par un max en 2007 l' indice de la
construction est passé par un max en
2007 la production industrielle est
passé par un max en 2007 ces populations
européennes est un maximum de mycènes si
vous regardez l'allemagne l'italie
l'espagne sont déjà depuis brive est en
décroissance
oui mais on a un tel réservoir de
chômeurs que c'est pas ça qui explique
le fait que le pib baisse le pib enfin
la production industrielle baisse parce
qu'il a plus assez d'énergie qui rentre
en europe c'est juste ça le sujet de
cette machine qui fonctionne et donc on
est déjà dans un processus de
contraction dont l'état français ne va
pas enfin dans la république française
ne va pas tarder à se rendre compte
avant la fin du mandat de monsieur macro
et c'est dans ce contexte là qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à arbitrer nos priorités
donc le sujet et pas juste un sujet de
plomberie dans un monde qui continue à
ne pas poser de problèmes économiques
le problème est un problème d'arbitrage
et de projets qui a suffisamment de sens
pour résister aux soubresauts dans un
monde qui va être de plus en plus
adverse en termes de nombre de problèmes
à traiter de la question stratégique de
cette entreprise quel joueur dans un
monde à zéro carbone c'est la question
oui et notamment c'est la question à
savoir traiter les perdants parce qu'on
aura plein et c'est pas juste les
producteurs de combustibles fossiles je
peux vous dire que le modèle de
l'hypermarché est mort lebron le modèle
de la consommation de produits à bas
prix pour tout le monde est mort dans ce
monde là donc c'est beaucoup plus
profond que donc la tâche à laquelle
vous vous êtes les dernières salutaire
beaucoup plus ample encore que l'idée
que vous en faites vous avez vous occupé
très bien ce qu'on dit sur la grande
consommation
moi je suis élu donc en essonne
qu'est-ce qui en essonne dans ma
circonscription il ya siège mondial le
carrefour à 10 km vous avez la première
implantation d'amazon de livraison de
produits frais c'est sur une ancienne
base aérienne à côté vous avez une
nouvelle plateforme logistique de casino
le bilan carbone de ces deux modèles et
puis peu après avec costco aussi qui est
pas loin donc sa cause cause c'est tout
l'importation du monde entier à votre
porte pour pas cher est ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ya un dialogue à
avoir sur comment consomme qu'est ce
qu'on achète de quoi on a besoin et dans
notre territoire je peux vous dire que
ces questions qui prennent un tour très
très très concret c'est où sont les
emplois qui les créent et ensuite qu'est
ce qui se passe autour
amazon ça pour l'instar modèles de
camions dans une plate forme qui va dans
une base aérienne et qui inondent de
paris comment ont posé une vision
cohérente de décarbonation face à ça
c'est la question aux jeux politiques
l'enjeu politique c'est pour moi et je
reviens c'est comment dans chaque une
autre décision et vous n'avez pas
forcément être à ce stade satisfait de
tout celle qu'on a pu prendre depuis 12
mois et celle contre probablement été
prise depuis 30 ans c'est que chacune
qu'en commandant chaque une autre
décision on a cette réflexion de se dire
est ce que ce qu'on lance aujourd'hui
puisque ça une durée de vie généralement
longues
est-ce que c'est cohérent avec une
trajectoire de décarbonation alors vous
me dites les éoliennes anglais en mer
par exemple en exemple c'est peut-être
cohérent à court terme dans l'image
c'est pas forcément cohérent à long
terme dans à côté du problème à traiter
c'est à côté du problème donc par
exemple ça c'est une image qui a l'air
de remplir de problème est qu'il n'irait
pas vraiment typiquement sur la grande
distribution on a tout un sujet à se
poser moi quand je vois te la loi est
lent que j'ai voté la semaine dernière
où il ya dix jours j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'elle est dans la
réflexion sur réutilisé par exemple des
bureaux pour en faire des logements
ça me semble pas forcément être une
mauvaise idée d'un point de vue de milan
car vote
quand je vote la loi agriculture
alimentation on peut en débattre pendant
longtemps il ya quand même pas mal de
choses dedans qui disent il faut qu'on
arrive à recréer de la vraie rupture
cal qui sert des marchés d'alimentation
locaux il ya il faut qu'on arrive aussi
à faire une vraie transition sur les
intrants pour que la marge entre
guillemets de l'agriculteur soit pas
maximisé pour ceux qui lui vendent des
produits qui sont des intrants non non
biologique y compris les pesticides et
des engrais bref il ya plein de
réflexions
la question c'est est ce qu'on va assez
loin est ce que toutes nos décisions
sont prises à ce niveau là et est-ce
qu'on est cohérent dans chacune des
décisions bien parce qu'ils ont
probablement pas probablement pas etc
qui est très difficile c'est que quand
vous êtes dans la prise de décision en
fait vous êtes face à des options en
permanence et donc vous êtes devant des
choix où vous vous choisissez ans de
manière itérative des choses est-ce que
c'est cohérent dans l'ensemble si on
avait une vision d'un grand ordonnateur
stratégique planificateur sûr beaucoup
plus d'années que les cycles sur les
camps de travail et c'est pour ça que
l'horizon de temps est essentiel
on pourrait probablement y arriver mieux
parce qu'il n'ya pas ce que est ce que
cette volonté la stratégie cohérente
cette volonté oui je pense qu'elle
existe moi je vous pourrez tout petit
budget dont je m'occupe qui sont obligés
de la recherche parce qu'on a chacun
raison d'une ligne du budget ma bataille
en ce moment c'est la plus grande
qualité
le considérer qu'on ne peut pas demander
les chercheurs de chercher pour vraiment
trouver des choses si on gère l'objet
aller avec des horizons neuf mois parce
qu'en fait une annuité budgétaire à
nouveau l'état ces neuf mois donc ça
c'est des chaussures grand travail après
je pourrais vous dire on a une ambition
dévorante elle est formidable
faites nous confiance tout va marcher
oui on a une ambition qui est bien sûr
évidente qui est bien sûr bon enfin la
france quand on fait la cap 21 qui en
fait de loin de planète ce mythe
quand on invite le m haïti à faire de la
recherche de pointe sur les modèles
climatiques avec lee psl et jussieu bien
sûr qu'on a une ambition est ce qu'elle
est suffisante
je ne peux pas le dire est ce qu'elle
est complètement cohérente je pense que
probablement il ya des choses qu'on
pourrait voir qu'ils ne sont pas
cohérentes
est-ce que itérative manche aucune
décision ce sujet est débattu par
exemple entre nos députés
la réponse est oui et je pense que c'est
nouveau je pense que c'est nouveau que
dans les débats qu'on à chacune de co2
commission on a toujours des gens qui se
posent des questions - la commission des
finances du petit périmètre où j'ai un
petit peu de pouvoir de décision
on vient de lancer une mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle sur les
outils
fiscaux et budgétaires qui encouragent
ou qui n'encourage pas l'investissement
privé pour être l'investissement privé
pour la transition verte
en gros je résume est-ce que les outils
budgétaires et les niches fiscales qu'on
met en place elle vraiment les ménages à
prendre les bonnes décisions
je crois que vous avez été auditionné
dans ce cadre là non mais si vous l'avez
pas déjà été mais les rôles qui mène les
travaux vers avons contrés donc voilà si
sinon le chiffre a été auditionné will
chiffre à drame moi non d'accord mais
bon chiffre shift en tant que président
du film alors le chiffre donc voilà
l'oms la commission des finances non ce
que péniche fiscal on se pose des
questions est ce que les niches fiscales
sert la transition on va rendre un
rapport est ce que la commission des
documents que j'arrive pas les questions
oui et je peux vous dire qu on en parle
tout le temps tout le temps on n'est pas
perçu comme étant une majorité écolo
pourtant il ya quand même plein
d'écologie chez nous il ya plein de gens
qui comme moi avant je vous parle vous
aurez peut-être jamais dit que j'étais
avec cette fibre verte là parce que ça
se voit pas sur le nez il n'y a pas
écrit toi tu es vers toi tu n'es pas et
je vois là moi je suis arrivé on aurait
donc je suis très gêné parce que ce
débat
j'ai cru comprendre que je crois qu'en
france on a le droit quand même de
rouler électrique
je voudrais comme vous devez nous
quitter à 8 heures j'aurai qu'on
commence à prendre des questions des
questions de la salle
c'est pas moi qui ai distribué chez
chargé de la distribution des micros
donc s'il vous plaît si vous pouvez
adresser une première question à madame
le député qui doit les premières
questions et enfin quid et parce que
j'ai une salle de aussi rempli de la
vôtre qui m'attend sur l'europe
côté budget européen d'où je vais leur
parler de verre aussi et encore il faut
que je fasse un petit transition jusqu'à
l'assemblée ou au matin vers 8 heures
oui bonjour donc pire les chaises
consultants indépendants
je vois bien le discours général qui
consiste à dire il ya beaucoup d'argent
un peu partout compris dans vos poches
non vous n'êtes pas de retraite et ainsi
de suite
mais je vois absolument pas le mécanisme
qui va faire que tous ces
investissements vont aller vers la
transition écologique quand je prends un
exemple on a parlé de total dont les
taux ont investi sur le solaire mais ça
c'est dans les 2% total il a il en train
d'investir énormément pour faire une
exploitation gazière en sibérie je crois
quelque chose de formidable
il est en train de faire la plus grande
plateforme offshore
ils vont creuser à plus de 2000 mètres
sous le niveau de l'océan est encore
4000 mètres en dessous
ils sont en train d'investir massivement
pour sortir du gaz sortir du pétrole
ainsi de suite et les autres sinon
comment on fait que ces investissements
là qui sont les instruments
d'aujourd'hui qui sont il y aura
d'autres plateformes qui sont projetés
d'autres champs gaziers ça se transforme
en investissement pour que moi gizolme
mon appartement macau pro et tout ça je
vois absolument pas sauf à rentrer dans
du dirigisme absolue on dit on arrête
totalement toute nouvelle forme de
nouveaux gisements toutes nouvelles lois
françaises
oui sur le sur le territoire oui mais il
ya assez peu de paix y compris qu'on
vaut d'histoire alors vous n'avez rien
n'a pas non mais je n'admets quand même
et donc ça me fait quand on va chercher
en guyane total total on doit pas trop
bête
non mais ça me fait très peur parce que
le discours qui consiste à dire il ya
beaucoup d'argent donc c'est pas la
peine d'en trouver les façons dont
d'autres façons d'en trouver pour que
les isolations elle se fasse le
changement du modèle agricole il se
fasse parce que je vois pas comment des
autres c'est très grands investissements
ils vont se transformer sur des choses
concrètes dans les années qui arrivent
et donc j'ai peur que ça ça soit une
façon de
ben de reculer ou d'attendre ou une
perte du temps où tous les cas toujours
la question de l'urgence et de la
cohérence madame de montréal alors je
peux faire un sondage qui entend d'entre
vous a une assurance vie portée par axa
cnp ou alliance
bon voilà vous êtes plein est ce que
vous savez que votre assurance vie
n'avait investi dans aucun projet chars
de charbon dans le monde
certains disent oui la majorité venir
dont donc il ya 2 il ya deux niveaux
dans votre question il ya il ya toute
une tuyauterie qui peut se mettre en
place et aujourd'hui même si ces acteurs
communiquent sur leurs décarbonation de
bilan vous n'êtes pas forcément vous
conscient de la réallocation de l'argent
qui font sa première chose ensuite
comment vous ça vous donne de l'argent
pour investir dans votre innovation un
exemple intéressant la bnp s'est lancé
dans la structuration de produits
dérivés dont jeudi sur les économies
d'énergie des bâtiments
il a lancé ça il ya quatre ans nous
expliquer en gros c'est une obligation
et l'intérêt est versé fin le coupon est
la différence entre la facture d'énergie
que paient le propriétaire est ce que il
paye pas parce que il a bien isolé et
donc on dit aux propriétaires de
logements pour toi ça change rien pour
la planète c'est super et on pousse à
des gens qui t'ont financer des travaux
et donc le sud qui vit dans vos travaux
et payée sur l'économie d'énergie
générées et la houle acteurs financiers
jouent c'est que l'économie générée
baisse elles se voient tous les ans mais
qu'à la fin il faut quand même avoir 20
ans pour que à la fin vous ayez un plus
et ça que je joue l'acteur ces
instruments là ils sont devenus
intéressant quand les grands acteurs
institutionnels sont dit ça nous
intéresse d'avoir un horizon de temps de
20 ans qui permettent de décarbonés de
bilan parce qu'il met ça en face
d'entreprise qui aujourd'hui continue de
progresser au 2010 voilà quinze ans j'ai
ça qui m'a économise et anton j'ai ça
qui m'a la produit et donc j'ai
décarbonés autrement qu'en plantant des
arbres
cette logique là elle est extrêmement
puissante mais il faut qu'on fasse
beaucoup d'ingénierie financière pour
que vous dans votre maison vous puissiez
faire la même chose donc là aujourd'hui
on le fait sur des grands immeubles
grand bâtiment parce que la bnp a trouvé
ces acteurs là mais à terme on pourrait
très bien de faire chez les particuliers
hier edf pourrait venir vous voir
certificats d'économie d'énergie vous
allez me payer le même prix la grille
citer tous les ans je vous donne de
l'argent vous y verrez vos fenêtres vous
aller polluer moins voire maîtres moi et
en plus vous avez payé votre amour pour
vous c'est neutre
donc ça c'est les choses qui peuvent se
titrisées qui veut se mettre dans les
bilans que des acteurs peuvent porter et
qui demandent pas ces réallocations de
l'argent ça ne résout pas le problème
qui a effectivement des choses nouvelles
qui vaut confidences
je pense
et donc il joue un peu le rôle des
banques c'est très petit ça c'est
beaucoup plus petit que ce que le
mécanisme qu'on vient d'éclore bon sens
mais ces petits il ya eu de conjugaison
de mille petites choses actuellement sur
un problème aussi énorme que la
rénovation de la rénovation des
logements anciens rennais qui est une
passoire énorme qui en parle de montants
de sur tous les bâtiments avant 1973
c'est énorme et les choses les choses
n'avancent pas alors que la queue des
mouvements qui se passe sur
l'avertissement de la finance et et axa
est un exemple merveilleux accent ces 12
milliards de financement versé moins 3
milliards de de retrait de financement
salle beau mais que que des choses se
passent le financement des 90 pour 7 %
de l'industrie
certes mais je pense qu'il n'ya pas
aucune opposition entre la constatation
que sur le d'autres champs qui sont des
chants de plutôt de rénovation plutôt
que d'extension de construction les
choses ne bougent pas sur le logement
la situation est tellement complexe qui
qui saurait je serais pas ici qui a
lancé un une vraie rénovation complète
de ceux de son habitation à vos complète
ou plusieurs
c'est à dire l'intégration c'est plus
courant en allemagne que
dérogation de
lala alors les les années que j'ai cités
jeu j'avais en tête c'est la durée des
obligations que la fameuse bnp a
structuré ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas les investissements qui peuvent être
faits probants pour que ça soit un truc
comme ça faut être dans la pire des
passoires énergétiques et se chauffer
avec une énergie très cher parce que
prend d une maison qui prend dit bill
kilowattheure de gaz par an gaz et à 5
centimes dont vous avez 500 euros de
factures de chauffage par an vous
rénovez vous diviser sa part de 250
euros d'économie vous allez dépenser 30
mille euros temps de retour un siècle
aux reportages des intérêts il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas un tiers financier qui va
financer ça a pas un micro machin dans
un coin d'un truc qui a 500
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
est chauffé au fioul mais à part ça ça
ne flotte jamais donc on peut dire que
tous les hlm que vous voyez le long des
autoroutes en région ile-de-france sont
globalement des bons candidats parce
qu'en fait le boulot dans les loges les
bailleurs sociaux sur les attentions
font des trucs ça je suis d'accord mais
en plus en plus ils ont des problèmes de
récupération de leurs charges etc mais
ce que je voulais dire c'est que pour le
groupe du parc
donc quand on regarde les rénovations
lourdes sérieuses autour du en france on
est à dix villes parents fort est monté
à sept cent mille par an là dedans on le
fera jamais sans obligation il faut que
l'obligation à léran peuple parce que
sinon on va pas la mettre au vert night
il faut que les effectifs qui savent
faire parce que les gens qu'on fait là
dans la salle si l'on fait l'ensemblier
l'entreprise générale de travaux pour
leur propre compte ça de quoi je parle
moi j'ai fait un peu aussi c'est un
bordel sans nom je veux dire il faut
coordonner le plombier le masson le mec
juste infernale donc il faut des gens
qui savent faire il faut des gens qui
inspire confiance
il faut qu' il ya une conditionnalité
aux subventions avec des tests qui
montrent que la performance est vraiment
là donc il faut aussi une coercition du
côté des gens qui vont être de l'autre
des gens et nous ferons des diagnostics
très cher et qui nous met dans une
lettre là vous savez puis on sait pas
trop mais non mais c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ya on repose sur près de la
mise en cohérence qui est évoqué tout à
l'heure par mathieu aujourd'hui il ya
des tas de trucs qui sont faits dans les
coins il n'y a pas de mise en cohérence
donc je vais le dire autrement
je pense qu'aujourd'hui monsieur macron
pour lui c'est pas un sujet c'est à dire
que si c'était un vrai sujet est pas
encore non c'est pas un sujet
aujourd'hui a précisé aujourd'hui
demain est un autre jour si c'était un
vrai sujet il aurait une vraie mise en
cohérence de sa devient un critère de
tri dire que c'est une mise en cohérence
c'est un critère de tri c'est à dire ça
je fais ça je fais pas ça je fais ça je
fais pas ça je fais ça je fais pas donc
au titre du climat je ne chercherai pas
augmenter le trafic d'adp et pays voilà
donc je mets adp sur marché avec un
trafic aérien décroissant puisque je
m'occupe du climat voilà c'est ça la
mise en cohérence et sa à des
contreparties aujourd'hui e on n'accepte
pas au sommet de l'état parce qu'on
continue à raisonner avec je vais avoir
le beurre et l'argent du beurre
je suis garant de la cohérence de débat
monsieur attend depuis longtemps et
wallemme de montchanin va pas tarder à
devoir nous quitter je vais lancer un
visionnaire excusez moi guillaume plouin
gpo c'est pour le chiffre sur le
placement efficacité énergétique en fait
je me pose la question la mobilisation
du grand public on a dit tout à l'heure
que pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
il ya eu un effort de guerre
considérable pour se débarrasser des
nazis et c'est à dire que si on regarde
un petit peu ce que disent les
scientifiques aujourd'hui les
scientifiques disent on part quand même
vers les 5 degrés c'est quand même assez
mal barré pour rester en dessous des
trucs de 2
et si on considère qu'on permet les 5
degrés alors je vais provoquant mais il
ya un risque de défendre eux m'enfin de
dauphin de l'humanité quoi et alors
finalement pourquoi on peut le grand
public et pas au courant de ça pourquoi
le parce que ça pourrait être une
mobilisation considérable quand même de
d'avoir cette analyse du problème a
l'impression d'être un peu en apesanteur
depuis la signature de l'accord de paris
pardon qui veut répondre là-dessus à
cette évidence cette évidence
moi je vous dis en un an chaussée alors
j'ai une petite expérience du débat très
très public très locale j'ai fait la
grande marche pour l'europe qui était
l'idée de faire caler votre europe non
pas dans des grandes salles met en porte
à porte
je suis étonné du nombre de fois où
spontanément des gens rendent hop vous
sonnez oui j'en vous ouvrons jour où
vous ouvre pas donc ccp ya pas de
sondages demi sociologique c'est un je
suis étonné du nombre de fois où le
l'idée que l'europe soit un vrai acteur
pour la transition climatique revient
sur les marchés à la sortie des gares
dans les rues je pense qu'il ya une
conscience que c'est important
après je pense pas que le degré
d'urgence et surtout les conséquences
que ça rassure nos modes de vie
individuelle soit comprise c'est que y'a
il ya l'idée oui c'est bien oui c'est
important qu'on ait un bon mise de
l'écologie c'est important qu'on ait un
grand discours diplomatique soit le
tribun c'est important qu'ils des choses
qui se passent et que vous les
politiques vous occupiez il n'ya pas
encore aujourd'hui de vrais
compréhension de ce que ça veut dire à
titre individuel c'est d'où l'urgence de
l'âme de ce qui peut se passer entre
octobre et décembre prochain il ya une
fenêtre de tir incroyable entre les
dates que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
et une mobilisation citoyenne possible
les gens actuellement soit on est tous
comme des lapins qui regardent les
phares de la voiture on bouge pas il y
as qui qui va nous pousser à bouger moi
je vais rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense qu'aujourd'hui alors dans
toutes les choses très critique que j'ai
pu dire je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
terreau est là pour qu'il puisse y avoir
un vrai projet politique dans lequel il
ya une grosse part de sueur
à partir du moment où en face on donne
de l'espoir et donc les gens à mon avis
seront prêts à accepter des
modifications significatives de leurs
modes de vie ce qui va passer par des
restrictions pour pas avoir peur
d'employer les mots si en face ou leur
dit où ils ont un avenir dans le job
qu'ils vont faire et dans le lac compte
la contribution au projet collectif qui
vont pouvoir avoir et ça ça passe par le
fait d'attaquer les filières parce que
si vous dites aux gens il y aura des
jobs pour s'occuper d'être couvreur
zingueur plombier maraîchers etc
on donne un discours individuels et
locales au sens de jeu je donne des
destins individuels en phase de jeu
demande des efforts individuels
tant qu'on est dans le grand propos
incantatoire général mais qu'on n'a pas
nommé
ce qu'on allait faire concrètement au
niveau des individus à qui on allait
demander d'agir et pour faire quoi
je pense qu'il n'y a aucune chance que
les gens acceptent les efforts qui sont
la contrepartie du plan d'ensemble
parce qu'ils voient la charge ils voient
pas le produit donc la raison pour
laquelle vous faites le dire en
politique parce qu'en vrai si les garder
on a fait la réforme de l'apprentissage
qui est à mon avis une réforme qui peut
amener beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans
l'emploi pour des métiers dont on a
besoin qu'ils sont tous les métiers que
vous aimez écrire et on a fait aussi la
part génération spontanée
oui il faut le projet d'ensemble
exactement parce qu'on a aussi fait
l'augmentation part atteint l'âge d'or
carbone la contribution énergie sur le
gasoil et je peux vous dire que moi j'ai
bien l'impression que ça va avec
je pense qu'il faut aimer dans la
pédagogie la pédagogie de l'ensemble
sera complète le jour où j'entendrai
aussi gouvernement dira par ailleurs je
mets adp sur le marché avec un trafic
aérien des croissants j'insiste
aujourd'hui on n'est pas cohérent donc
on a les gens sont pas cons les gens ne
sont pas qu'on a l'impression que ils
font des efforts et d'autres non mais
ils comprennent bien que on tire à hue
et à dia ils sont pas cons les unes de
parole me suis amusé position sur la
question
bonjour bonjour à vous je suis rigoureux
bavent ingénieur en aéronautique
merci de ces présentations il ya des
dirigeables après plus près il plaidera
parlons excusez mon bonjour donc je suis
monsieur grégoire balland ingénieur en
aéronautique
et justement je profite de votre
intervention en rebondissant sur votre
propos à propos des adp est donc la
décroissance du trafic aérien
mais si cette question s'adresse à tous
les intervenants bien sûr au port de
paris poursuit oui un report de paris
c'est exactement qu'effectivement
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes pour en
commençant donc à savoir que par exemple
les yeux a bel et bien dit que
effectivement on atteindrait
certainement le pétrolier en tout cas en
énergies fossiles dans les années 2020
dans la décennie 2020 etc enfin on voit
bien qu'il va y avoir une stress en
termes d'énergies fossiles
certainement et moi je me questionne en
temps dans vos propos à savoir pourquoi
est ce que si on sait qu'on va avoir un
stress énergétique que donc du coup le
kérosène va coûter de plus en plus cher
on voit pourtant des compagnies comme
airbus ou encore boeing prévoir plus de
1000 commandes chacun sur les dix
prochaines années on prévoit d'embaucher
pour l'oaci plus de 600 mille pilotes
sur les dix prochaines années aussi en
club de ligne alors même qu'ils savent
que le kérosène pour une compagnie
aérienne en moyenne c'est 30% de leurs
dépenses
donc comment expliquer justement cette
cette incongruité si on veut dans le
monde économique alors même que tout le
monde a accès à ces informations
merci une question complémentaire
oui j'ai une question excusez moi de
répondre à des questions éventuelles
manger une question complémentaire par
rapport aux 10 messieurs moi ce que j'ai
pas pouvoir a coûté beaucoup jean marc
jancovici et pour connaître le travail
dames et une manche à rien il manque
quelque chose à l'assemblée nationale tu
avec tes collègues voulaient lancer un
office parlementaire pour avoir accès
aux données économiques et sociales en
gros vous avez plus besoin de quémander
pendant deux mois avec des courriers
avec accusé de réception
merci monsieur rondelle de faire la
publicité de mon action mais c'est
exactement ça voilà qui est demandé
pendant deux mois des chiffres que les
hauts fonctionnaires on à bercy que tout
député devrait avoir dans la seconde et
le difficultés de jean marc et nous
ingénieurs et passionné du sujet c'est
que 1 les 577 députés n'ont pas
conscience du problème ni des solutions
pourquoi pas intégrer de base dans ce
futur office que tout déjà pour éduquer
excuse moi le terme les députés les
sensibiliser sur le problème et je
tenais de trois problèmes pour ton
budget aux pays européens
nous allons dépasser en dépendance
énergétique dans l'europe à 80% nous
devons apporter le pétrole gaz et
charbon
avec 80% à cause de la flambée
pétrolière nord est après le gros
problème fermer des centrales à charbon
s'est demandé aux allemands de fermer
leurs centrales à charbon et faire des
voitures de litres aux cent s'est
demandé aux allemands de faire des clio
et pas des mercedes ou des 4 4 2 2
tonnes donc là il ya des sujets
européens mais je comprends bien que
cette pression sur les allemands ne va
pas dans le sens mais je crois que yahoo
si les députés savent faire savent ce
qui se passe quels sont les problèmes
sont les solutions
je pense quand ils font leurs réunions
circonscription ils sont ils ont encore
deux meilleurs discours madame le rouge
alors je vais répondre après je m'en
vais c'est pas parce que voilà mais vous
avez bien compris sur les avions
dans ma jolie circonscription via safran
safran le l'élément de compétitivité
aujourd'hui de tous les accessoiristes
où les motoristes d'avion c'est
d'arriver à faire des moteurs qui gagne
20 ou 15 ou 30 % de l'efficacité de non
consommation de kérosène par an badetz
sera zéro mais paris pendant par gsm par
modèle pardon pas par an art modell donc
on est de chaque génération de moteurs
par par type de modèle d'avion on est on
essaie de couper de 15 20 voire 30%
sachez que l'état français ait investi
135 millions d'euros par an 135 millions
d'euros par an en plus du crédit impôt
recherche pour financer cette recherche
sur des avions qui consomment beaucoup
beaucoup moins de kérosène sur les
question je réponds et effectivement on
travaille pour les chiffres de bercy
en parallèle cédric villani lui est très
mobilisée pour que nous ayons une
commission permanente de la science et
de la technologie qu'ils puissent saisir
pour avis et ça va être un élément qu on
espère important de tous les textes qui
passe si vous avez à l'assemblée à
chaque fois qu'il ya un texte par
exemple la loi de transition énergétique
qui passe et quelques années à
l'assemblée et ont dit on va faire 75%
de doit passer de 75 points de terre à
50% du clair et que tout le monde vote
sans cesse jamais posé la question si
techniquement et technologiquement
c'était possible avec une telle
commission et déjà qu'ils vont dire
faisait en fait en hongrie
c'est ma possible si on peut avoir cette
commission qui a dans son mandat
sciences et technologies notamment la
science du climat comme vous dites les
flux physiques qui eux ne mentent jamais
on va pouvoir savoir si quand on propose
par exemple une loi sur le logement qui
dit on veut réduire de 20% la
consommation ou la dépense d'énergie de
ses bâtiments
est ce qu'on s'est bien donné les moyens
scientifiques et techniques d'y arriver
donc c'est pas forcément de l'évaluation
sait déjà qu'on remette de la science et
de l'art et de la recherche et donc
d'une réflexion technologique dans la
fabrique du politique et vidal dit c'est
ça use for politics dire que que la
décision de politique publique se pose
quand même la question de faisabilité
technique ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
toujours se dire que c'est faisable
aujourd'hui mais que si on a vraiment
envie de le faire politiquement et que
la science débat prête
eh ben on puisse du coup inclure le coût
de l'investissement technologique pour y
arriver
le shift le shift avait essayé il ya
quelques mois de porter auprès d'un
certain nombre de présidents de
commission à l'assemblée nationale
l'idée de faire une mission
d'information permanente sur la mise en
oeuvre des accords de paris qui aurait
notamment la capacité à évaluer la
cohérence de n'importe quelle décision
bâlois pacte y compris avec le fait
qu'on va baisser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'elle aurait énormément de
boulot parce que la réponse est non de
manière systématique
c'est à dire qu'en fait sans s'en rendre
compte la quasi totalité des décisions
qu'on prend de manière législatives en
dehors du champ compris comme étant
strictement celui du climat et
orthogonale enfin vous présente des
caractéristiques orthogonale avec ce
qu'on décide dans le climat donc une
telle mission d'information permanente
aurait la capacité notamment à travers
la publicité des auditions qui sont
quand même un bon vecteur de diffusion
d'un débat structuré d'un débat stature
est ce que les gens qui viennent y parle
deux heures et à fabrègues il y avait
vraiment un truc non mais je le sais que
vous travaillez leleu ça serait un bon
un bon moyen à mon avis de commencer à
faire naître un débat sur ce problème de
mise en cohérence dont pour répondre à
la question posée à peu près personne
n'a conscience et pas plus les
dirigeants des motoristes que les autres
dont vous dites tout le monde est au
courant qu'ils alpilles le pic de
production du pétrole en 2020 je peux
vous dire la fraction des gens dans le
monde économique qui ont conscience du
fait que non seulement c'est en 2020
mais pour pétrole conventionnel c'est
arrivé il ya dix ans et à peu près
nulles
elle est à peu près nul à peu près
partout
je crois qu'on peut remercier madame de
chalain seront plus disponibles
[Applaudissements]
si à bientôt je pense qu'on peut pour
finir là tu reviens qu'à mon niveau
quand je te prends contre un dirigeant
dans le monde économique et julie vous
savez que la production de pétrole
conventionnel
elles baissent depuis 2006 dans le monde
i'm non conventionnelles or or celle aux
îles et par sens et que non c'est aux
etats-unis que ce stade est le seul
président non mais là dedans tu as les
personnes du canada tard sens du canada
donc ça ça et ça stagne vous savez ce
peu importe
et que du coup le
dans la zone ocde c'est déjà en
contraction
l'approvisionnement pétrolier ça se voit
dans les stats lui ai pas besoin
les gens me regardent avec des yeux
comme des soucoupes ya personne n'y
croit donc là on est aujourd'hui en ce
qui concerne cette histoire de pétrole
comme on était vis-à-vis du climat dans
les années 80 exactement pareil c'est
dire que les gens qui regardent vraiment
les statistiques savent que le problème
ait déjà commencé dans un certain nombre
de zones et imminent ailleurs mais c'est
une toute toute petite fraction des gens
qui auraient besoin de savoir tout petit
si vous n'êtes pas lassé du débat on
peut encore prendre quelques questions
pourquoi poursuivre les échanges autour
du jean neige en été déposé je vais me
l'imposé bonjour à tous je m'appelle
stéphane edouard je suis ingénieur en
mécanique et sociologues
j'ai grandi dans les années 80 je ne
pense pas être le seul dans la salle et
dans les années 80 on entendait souvent
dans les cours de récréation une blague
n'était pas la plus courte et pas la
plus drôle mais qui m'a marqué et cette
blague disait qu est ce qu un monde
idéal alors le monde idéal c'était un
monde où les anglais faisait des blagues
les français faisait la cuisine l'amour
ou l'amour
les italiens faisait la mode et les
allemands faisait les voitures et donc
ensuite on disait qu'elle est le l'enfer
quelle est la définition de l'enfer les
ans les allemands faisait l'humour les
anglais faisait la cuisine les français
elle et c'est donc je pense que cette
blague n'a pas être le seul dans la
salle à la crête sinon en introduction
tombe à plat évidemment j'espère qu'elle
ne tombe pas trop à plat j'ai la chance
ou la malchance pour les écologistes
forcené car ça va entraîner de la
pollution j'ai la chance d'habiter sur
trois pays et donc de pouvoir comparer à
la chaîne intra-européennes ce qu'ils
font de très bien est ce qu ils font de
très mal et donc là j'avais un petit peu
m'interroger sur votre recherche un peu
idéologique d'une solution paneuropéenne
outrance européenne alors qu'en réalité
on a à l'échelle intra européennes entre
chaque pays des choses qui font très
bien et des choses qui font très mal
donc là je suis un petit peu abstrait
exemple très simple je viens dit je suis
arrivé d'italie à deux heures j'ai une
maison en italie
l'italie fait une chose très bien c'est
le kilomètre zéro je vais au supermarché
il est évident sur chaque produit à
seulement made in italy mais km 077 ce
concombre cette aubergine n'a pas fait
plus de 10 ou 20 km avant d'être sur le
vin est en revanche l'italie fait très
mal
autre chose comme par exemple le fait
qu'ils n'étaient pas la lumière dans les
immeubles tous les immeubles sont
éclairés 24 24 y'a pas le timer j'ai
également une maison en espagne
tous les immeubles non mais ça va
intéresser monsieur jean cau visé parce
qu'il cherche le moyen d'imposer par la
tyrannie la rénovation des la rénovation
des immeubles en espagne le contrôle
technique est obligatoire pour les
immeubles
vous ne pouvez ni acheter ni vendre un
appartement si vous ne montrez pas le
contrôle technique de l'immeuble un
petit peu comme en france on a le
contrôle technique des autos en espagne
a le contrôle technique de l'immeuble
voilà donc on pourrait l'utiliser par
exemple comme un outil pour justement
faire passer le la rénovation
donc je suis d'accord qu'il faut faire
confluer une politique paneuropéenne
bright star
mais aujourd'hui pourquoi au lieu
d'envoyer monsieur jancovici que son
bâton de pèlerin entre bruxelles et
francfort ne donnerait ton pas à chaque
pays européen sur ce qu'il sait faire de
mieux
une mission d'évangélisation en disant
voilà moi je sais faire le kilomètre
zéro je vous happe je suis l'italie je
sais faire le kilomètre zéro jeu j'ai eu
six mois pour vous apprendre à le faire
également
et en revanche sur ce que je fais de
plus mal je me fais taper sur les doigts
l'espagne c'est faire le contrôle
technique des immeubles et bien elle a
six mois pour nous l'apprendre etc etc
cela me paraît un peu une version
jacobine aux européennes mais très
facile à faire pas si coûteuse pas si
longue et je parle de choses qui sont
très concrètes que je vis et que je
connais qui sont qui me paraissent pas
si compliqué à mettre en avant
[Applaudissements]
un petit élément de réponse ça ce que
vous proposez finalement c'est une
déclinaison autour d'un objectif de
décarbonation de ce qu'on fait avec
airbus
c'est à dire qu'on s'est dit on va faire
un truc en commun pas d'avion et puis on
va distribuer les tâches en essayant de
d'avoir quelque chose qui marche
ensemble avec chacun ayant un rôle dans
l'histoire
bon je la connaissais la blague là sur
les allemands etc
moi je la trouve assez bonne en fait foi
pourquoi que vous avez dit qu'elle
n'était pas bonne mais la 3e c'est ccl
existait avant la vie avant la fin des
années 80 et met alors le prérequis à ce
que vous suggérez ce qui me semble très
bon enfin je veux dire il faut que
chacun amène ce qu'il sait faire de bien
suppose de passer par la case départ qui
est de se retrouver autour d'un objectif
commun
donc c'est ce que j'ai essayé de dire
tout à l'heure qui était peut-être dit
maladroitement il faut accepter le fait
le prérequis de départ c'est que
l'europe doit avoir un objectif commun
qui a sa propre cohérence et par exemple
cet objectif commun c'est de créer une
économie décarbonée si on se dote de cet
objectif ce que vous proposez en devient
une déclinaison assez logique c'est à
chacun va dire ben moi j'ai une
compétence dans tel domaine donc j'ai
envie de la mettre au service de tout le
monde et puis si en plus je pouvais
gagner 3 euros au passage ça ferait bien
les affaires tant qu'on n'a pas cet
objectif en commun et que l'objectif
c'est de réduire le déficit budgétaire
vous pouvez y aller aux jo on s'en fout
il n'y a pas de lien entre ça et le fait
de laisser la lumière allumée dans
l'immeuble pendant la nuit
donc le l'obstacle à ce qui est évoqué
c'est en fait le truc qui paraît
peut-être le plus évident aux gens dans
cette salle mais c'est que la transition
énergétique n'est pas un objectif commun
en europe
elle n'existe pas la transition
européenne chacun a son objectif
national dire les allemands veulent
garder leur charbon les polonais veulent
pas du gaz russe les hongrois n'ont plus
les tchèques veulent du nucléaire les
hongrois et les roumains aussi les
autrichiens surtout pas les italiens non
plus enfin il y en a pas aujourd'hui de
transition énergétique européenne
c'est une vue de l'esprit c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous vous retrouvez
avec des directives européennes qui
mélange la chèvre et le chou demande des
trucs qui se marchent sur les pieds etc
il y en a pas donc alors comment est ce
que met l'europe l'europe n'est d'un
agrégat de pays
je veux dire l'europe allait pas née
d'une opération du saint-esprit il n'y a
pas eu de consensus à 28 au départ
départ il ya eu un petit groupe de pays
c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure il appartient un pays
politiquement puissant en europe
ayant décidé que c'était un objectif
pertinent pour l'avenir que d'essayer
d'optimiser notre destin sous contrainte
physique c'est ça la décarbonation de
l'économie de commencer à faire la
pédagogie de ce projet auprès d'un
certain nombre d'autres pays en disant
on va marcher ensemble
alors il ya des opportunités aujourd'hui
je pense que paradoxalement le break
site fournit une opportunité de rebattre
les cartes avec les anglais je pense que
la déshérence espagnoles et italiennes
fourni paradoxalement l'occasion de
rebattre les cartes avec ces pays je
pense que le seul avec qui on n'arrivera
à rien sur cet objectif de deckard lauda
sion c'est les allemands parce que ça a
été dit totalement c'est tout à leur
pardon ils font tout à l'envers
ils font tout à l'envers sur viennent de
créer une commission pour sortir du
charbon oui ils vont causer comme nous
mais pour le moment
pour le moment ils font tout à l'envers
c'est à dire qu'ils gardent leur charbon
ils sont pour les grosses bagnoles
ils sont pour l'industrie qui crachent
du co2 quand il s'agit de réglementer
les quotas de manière un peu plus dur
c'est le premier cas et c'est donc ils
sont juste à peu près contre tout
objectif climat au jour dans la pratique
un dans le court il court vite mais en
pratique ils sont contre je crois qu'ils
sont quand même je crois qu'ils sont
meilleurs que nous en rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et il ne faut
pas de saupoudrage ils ont une action a
fait quand on regarde la consommation de
combustibles fossiles dans le chauffage
des bâtiments en allemagne au niveau
macroscopique vois pas la différence
avec la france
beaucoup gaz et au charbon
monsieur oui bonjour marc chaussade
je suis citoyen concerné par les
affaires de climat mais pas du tout plus
que ça pas hyper militants et j'ai une
question d'une naïveté un peu effarant
je vous demande pardon
surtout pour monsieur cohen peut-être
vous avez mentionné qu'il y avait eu
beaucoup d'investissements dans les
faits beaucoup de fonds déployés pour la
transition
non pour le par la bce est que peu et
est allé à l'économie réelle et vous dit
et ensuite grand dans vos mesures vous
préconisez de taxer les bénéfices des
entreprises alors moi j'ai un peu
l'impression que vous allez prendre
l'argent dans l'économie réelle pour la
remettre à nouveau dans la finance
peut-être que je me trompe
par ailleurs ma tout micro expérience de
de quelqu'un qui essaye de financer les
études de ses enfants dans les fonds que
j'ai trouvé dans une banque une
excellente manque le fond j'ai pris des
fonds qui étaient dressés pour les leurs
études donc je suis un peu loin tout ça
et j'ai pris un fond un peu long terme
et puis je me suis dit bon autant fait
un truc sympa donc j'ai pris un fond un
peu solidarité un peu climat un peu vert
et tout ça donc voilà j'ai regardé ça
mais je n'y connais rien mais je suis
allé voir après ce qu'il y avait
derrière et en fait le fonds solidarité
climat et cetera je crois enfin j'ai
peur de me tromper donc je vous dis pas
le nom de la banque mais je crois que
c'était 2,8 pour cent de mon argent qui
était en fait investi sur des trucs
verts climat et mâcha et j'en ai trop
chercher un autre champ qu'ils arrivent
monté presque 10 mais pas tout à fait
quand même et j'avais l'impression que
c'était un peu parce que comme il
voulait garantir un certain rendement ou
incertaine performance est bien quand
même il ya un moment faut être réaliste
alors madame de montchanin et partie
madame de montchanin est parti mais je
trouvais que son idée de dire ben est ce
qu'il peut pas y avoir d obligation pour
les banques de batte de même qu'ils ont
des obligations d'avoir des fonds je
crois de d'assurer un peu leur leurs
bases financières pour paraître en crise
est ce qu'ils peuvent pas aux noirs
aussi des obligations d'investissement
dus sur du très long terme
j'ai pas 10% de leurs fonds devraient
être investis toujours du très long
terme
voilà donc avec des choses avec plein de
contrôle passion aussi habituée alors
plein de contrôle hyper street est hyper
avec des tas de gens super qui
connaissent beaucoup mieux que moi tout
ça et qui pourrait mieux les évaluer la
team monsieur que vous mettez bien vous
mettez bien le doigt sur la toux le
greenwashing qui atterrit qui ce qui se
déploie en ce moment et
même s'il se passe réellement des choses
sérieuses dans le verdissement de la
finance c'était vraiment vraiment un
vrai exemple mais il ya également
beaucoup de beaucoup de ce que vous ce
que vous dénoncez alors que le que les 5
% d'impôt sur les bénéfices aille vers
la finance non ils vont pas vers la
finance ils vont vers les projets réels
et ya un fléchage encore plus fort pour
ça que le fléchage que l'on propose pour
le la finance ramener vers l'économie
réelle que la queue dans les deux que
dans la création monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne une énorme part ne
se retrouve pas dans l'économie réelle
c'est un fait c'est un fait je pense
qu'on prend une dernière question et on
pourra poursuivre la conversation entre
un verre ensuite juste juste eu de
remarques sur les on parlait des députés
de la conscientisation des députés sur
ces sujets je pierre larrouturou a été
auditionné par les deux commissions des
affaires européennes et du développement
durable il ya quinze jours
les députés se motive s'interroge pose
des questions et heureux et en
l'occurrence on en est à plus de 56 50
parlementaires signataires
et ça continue sur les citoyens on
raisonne peut-être trop souvent avec des
citoyens est aisé très informés très
conscientisé là si on prend l'exemple
simple de la rénovation énergétique
l'information abbé pierre évalué à 1 1
logement sur cinq des logements qui
serait qu'il ressemblerait de la
préquelle à de la précarité énergétique
un logement sur cinq toute cette
population de citoyens a envie de voir
des choses concrètes tangibles avoir un
autre regard sur l'europe
si l'europe arrive et que c'est que
derrière le déploiement de projet arrive
des choses simples claire lisible avec
un interlocuteur unique assurant aussi
bien la sécurisation financière la
sécurisation la sécurisation qualité
avec des interlocuteurs qui ne vont pas
des entreprises qui ne vont pas profiter
de l'effet d'aubaine pour pour
fragmenter faire n'importe quoi
les citoyens auront verront l'europe
différemment si elle est concrète comme
si une seule capitaliste à la tribune je
dois être d'accord avec vous faut pas
non je vais vous répondre ouais non faut
pas faut quand même être sérieux avant
non je vais je vais vous répondre sur un
exemple qui est que moi je suis d'accord
avec vous du pognon en a plein c'est pas
le sujet d'accord avec amélie de
montchanin c'est pas le sujet de la
quantité de pognon c'est ronde en fait
aujourd'hui à fin 2017 et 2017 ou 2016
le rapport de la cour des comptes
les 121 milliards c'est à fin 2017 je
crois à fin 2017
nous savons que les ménages français
vont payer 121 milliards pour financer
les panneaux solaires et les éoliennes
installées à fin 2010 721 milliards ce à
quoi on vient de décider d'en rajouter
25 accords dont nous parlons maintenant
de 136 milliards
avec 136 milliards d'euros je paye une
pompe à chaleur
dix mille euros pièce à 15 millions ce
qu'on va quand même faire quelques
progrès à 15 millions de foyers c'est à
dire à peu près la totalité des foyers
français qui sont chauffés au gaz et au
fioul
j'aurais pris la même quantité d'argent
dans vos poches puisque c'est payé par
une taxe sur l'électricité maintenant
une taxe sur les carburants change pas
je continue à apprendre et s'est pris
dans les poches et c'est une vraie
opposition vraiment pris dans les poches
des ménages français ça fait monter les
factures d'électricité et maintenant un
peu les factures de carburant
sauf que je les redistribuer d'une façon
totalement différente
je vous signale au passage que ça fait
beaucoup plus de dépenses par ménage que
les 5 euros d'apl sur lesquels ont réglé
personne n'a rien dit et le cet argent
donc permettrait de supprimer 15% du
pétrole qu'on apporte donc selon les
années ça va représenter n'importe quoi
entre 4 et 9 milliards et le chauffage
au gaz en france et 55 60 % du chauffe
alors il ya des tertiaires l'admettons
le chauffage des ménages avec 40% du gaz
qu'on consomme donc là vous rajouter
encore à paquet de milliards économisés
par an donc macroéconomique mans
s'intéressant pas pour le coup vous
créer de l'emploi vous débarrasser de 25
pour ce faire les 20% du co2 français
grosse maille vous avez dépensé la même
quantité d'argent donc le sujet
j'insiste là dessus il est marginalement
une question de quantité totale d'argent
je ne crois pas on est un problème de
quantité totale d'argent il est
principalement une question de fléchage
d'argent est fléché l'argent ça veut
dire
que vous changez le système
d'obligations et de récompense est là
par exemple si vous voulez payer une
pompe à chaleur à chaque français qui
est chauffé au gaz et au fioul
vous avez l'obligation et la récompense
donc la récompense et je vous en
subventionnant 80% l'obligation s'est il
est interdit
le jour où votre chaudière à gaz votre
chaudière à fuel tombe en panne de faire
autre chose que de changer par une pompe
à chaleur et si vous faites autre chose
vos impôts fonciers triple voilà donc
vous faites ça non mais vous faites ça
c'est qu'on vous n'avez pas besoin de
plus d'argent et vous régler une partie
de votre problème
donc je j'insiste vraiment sauf que je
reviens à ce que je disais au début de
l'intervention pour faire ça vous avez
besoin d'une approche par filière si
vous avez une approche transversale sur
le prix du co2 la finance etc
vous vous plantez il faut avoir une
approche par filière et derrière
regarder ce que l' approche par filière
commandes sur les instruments
transversaux des fois ça va demander une
fois ça va rien demandé du tout donc
c'est vraiment comme ça qu'il faut s'y
prendre
le gros problème de cette approche par
filière c'est que ça empêche le discours
politique généralistes que vous êtes
obligés de prendre les problèmes à paris
on me dit qu'il nous reste pas mal de
temps on fait pour des questions mais
l'on sait bonjour la le jus d'orange est
pas encore là alexandre trop pige
travail sur la transformation numérique
des entreprises
on ya trente ans déjà on a diminué par
exemple chez goodyear la conception d'un
pneu de 83 semaine et en fait ce qui
m'inquiète un peu c'est alors une mine
une image que monsieur sa blague - comme
la grande tente a eu alzheimer ma mère
est très inquiète parce que c'est un
truc dont on ne meurt pas et qui durent
très longtemps et c'est là que le
médecin nous a rassurés nationale de
chimie ça passera avant est en fait moi
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est qu'en fait le réchauffement
climatique
on va le voir c'est grave mais j'ai peur
qu'un effondrement dû à une diminution
de l'énergie disponible arrive avant et
[ __ ] en l'air en fait les bonnes
nouvelles pour vous on va avoir les deux
oui c'est ce que vous savez lire là mais
je veux dire
alors pour moi eu un truc comme
interdire en france l'extension
pétrolière c'est une sorte d'image on se
donne à l'étranger en face et c'est
enfantin c'est
et alors d'autres trucs qui serait
intéressant par exemple c'est lui hier
que les allemands enfin et cela mettrait
son usine de batteries en allemagne
c'est peut-être pas mieux de remettre en
alsace à côté de fessenheim et faire
tomber la semaine mon voile alimenter un
joueur comme ça enfin je veux dire
continuer et c'est comme on parlait
avant de la arrêter les investissements
dans le pétrole ça ça va tuer et faire
effondrer l'économie très vite parce que
pétrole c'est ce qui fait rouler tout le
monde est donc aujourd'hui même chez bp
alors à outlook 2010 est ils ont
expliqué très bien le chief economist à
vie la courbe est de pour le les deux
degrés c'est ça maintenant si on arrête
tous les agissements
c'est 3% par an diminution immédiatement
et donc ça ça nous casse tout donc en
fait il faut ménager un peu tout est
alors les deux degrés en fait c'est
encore plus que ça c'est si on commence
demain matin c'est quoi ces cinq quelque
chose pour cent par an les deux
avant-hier met donc en fait ce que vous
est ce que c'est une autre manière de
dire que les deux degrés s'est
terriblement récessif
enfin je veux dire il n'y a pas moyen de
faire autrement que de faire à l'idée
d'en voir les cessions ou pour faire les
deux et voilà donc en fait tous les gens
qui disent qu'on va faire 2 degrés avec
les codes amis constante ils sont tous
en train de se raconter des histoires
parce que vous aurez alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on n'aura pas
l'économie constante indéfiniment à
cause de ce que vous avez dit sur les
combustibles fossiles le alors je vais
commencer par la blague caustique et
ensuite est un peu plus sérieux la
blague caustique si vous allez avoir les
deux c'est à dire que compte tenu du
temps de résidence du co2 dans
l'atmosphère qui se comptent en milliers
d'années avant vous envoyer plus la
trace vous allez avoir la baisse des
combustibles fossiles et les problèmes
climatiques qui vont continuer à
augmenter à ce moment là d'accord vous
allez avoir le double effet kiss cool
alors dans cette affaire-là
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure il faut faire
de l'optimisation sous contrainte c'est
vraiment le truc qui est le boulot
d'ingénieurs au service de la société
c'est-à-dire que vous avez une
contrainte qui est que votre espace de
libertés se réduisent et la dent vous
devez trouver le max de bonheur possible
avec ce qui vous reste comme moyen c'est
vraiment ça le mandat qu'on a sur la
table
je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
vous n'y arriverez jamais avec un effort
collectif si vous faites pas la
pédagogie de l'effort si vous faites pas
l'exposer du problème qui nous attend
vous n'y arriverez jamais si vous donnez
pas chacun à chaque électeur à voir ce
que son destin personnel dans cette
affaire donc là où ils souffrent mais la
brigade vous êtes obligé de donner cette
équation personnelle parce que sinon les
gens il ya des repas et vous êtes obligé
de justifier votre critères de tri au
choix en disant je vais aider les impies
je vais pas aider les autres parce que
je peux pas aider tout le monde parce
que je peut transposer la maxime célèbre
de rocard qui on peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde donc c'est pas
traiter tous les problèmes à la fois
c'est juste pas possible eh bien
aujourd'hui
cette grille de lecture derrière elle
permet de mettre les moyens en cohérence
elle permet de les hiérarchiser et donc
peut-être qu'avec cette grille de
lecture vous vous rendrez compte même
vous qui êtes dans le numérique que
c'est plus important de réadapter le
modèle agricole à quelque chose qui
permet de se nourrir avec pas trop loin
et des trucs qui résiste à un climat qui
va changer
il ya des moyens de faire tout ça plutôt
que de continuer avec pas d'argent dans
le chatt bottes qui va vous répondre à
la place de votre conseiller bancaire
qui est parti en vacances pour vous
expliquer quoi faire si jamais vous avez
un problème sur votre pea enfin je veux
dire voilà c'est donc aujourd'hui on a
un sujet sur l'allocation des moyens et
je peux vous dire qu'on continue à faire
les trucs à l'envers tout à l'heure je
vais finir là-dessus ma chère école
d'origine
elle a décidé de faire une chaire trucs
qui m'énervent énormément de faire une
chair avec google sur l'intelligence
artificielle comme si on avait que ça à
[ __ ] que de fou que de que de filer
aux américains parmi les meilleurs
ingénieurs conforme en france pour les
faire des conneries fallu verser bon
donc c'est bien la preuve qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est juste pas en train d'organiser
nos moyens en face d'une hiérarchisation
qu'on a clairement explicité ce n'est
pas ça qu'on est en train de faire et il
faudrait le faire pour être capable de
faire la tortue des romains là c'est à
dire le gros dos face à un monde un peu
chahuté qui va nous attendre et
continuer quand même à trouver
l'existence sympathique dans ce monde là
juste par rapport à lire il ya une très
bonne étude qui est sorti pas ben c'est
une compagnie qui prédit enfin si on lit
entre les lignes il ya un effondrement
du à liane avant 2030
oui oui l'écriteau que moi je pense
aussi à cause du minage de crypto 46
bonsoir patrick hubert alors en fait
j'ai une remarque
la question donc la remarque c'est que
chaque yamani qui était ministre du
pétrole d'arabie saoudite nous a
fameusement dit que l'âge de pierre
s'était pas arrêtée parce qu'on avait
manqué de pierres et donc je pense que
lolo l'éocène ne va pas s'arrêter parce
qu'on manque de pétrole parce que si on
vraiment il y avait il y avait des
contraintes et je suis absolument pas
aussi pessimistes qu une bonne partie
des gens se soient si vraiment on avait
des contraintes sur le pétrole et le gaz
de schiste le pétrole et gaz de schiste
plus les les schistes bitumineux etc
nous permet de détendre mais si vraiment
on avait 7 contre 1 là on irait sur du
charbon et sasol avait repris le procédé
des allemands pour convertir le charbon
en combustible donc ils manquent pas on
a un problème c'est le climat est en
fait on a aussi une solution ce sont les
renouvelables je suis désolé ont
effectivement les contrats qui coûte
très cher aux français aujourd'hui ce
sont des contrats qui ont été mis en
place il ya 12 en en 2006 sur l'éolien
qui a été mis en place hier
non non non moi je parle du solaire je
parle du solaire et le gouvernement
avait poussé des cris d'orfraie bien
inspiré par edf et à juste titre ça
coûtait très cher
c'était 60 centimes le tarif de rachat
tct 60 centimes du kilowattheure
aujourd'hui la facture c'est facture edf
classique c'est 15 centimes
il ya depuis plus d'un an un certain
nombre de contrats qui tombe
que ce soit en arabie saoudite mais
aussi et plus étonnamment aujourd'hui
aux états unis où on est sur des prix de
rachat à 2 centimes 2 centimes du
kilowattheure et c'est toute la raison
c'est parce que on est passé d'un d'une
production qui était en quelques giga
watts par an il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui
à 100 gigawatts
et ça continue la croissance du marché
là que la croissance de la production
des panneaux c'est 40 % par an donc le
prix on est sur une énergie qui devient
une énergie industriel c'est comme les
télévisions c'est comme les ordinateurs
etc
saab scc industriel c'est systématique
le génie humain c'est ça c'est de savoir
faire baisser les coûts donc là il n'y a
pas je pense qu'il y aura pas de
problème énergie en termes la fin c'est
pas le fossile qui sera un problème et
c'est le climat qu'il est on est
d'accord et donc j'ai ma question
notamment à vous monsieur cohen on le
thème de la soirée c'était l'union à
long terme
donc est ce que aujourd'hui on parle de
la france c'était on a des bonnes idées
est ce que il ya des idées similaires
vous nous avez évoqué de deux pays où
vous avez des homologues qui
réfléchissent
est-ce que a plus que 3 est ce que
éventuellement à une demi-douzaine de
deux groupes convaincu vous êtes en
mesure de l'arrivée avec un projet
porteur celui qui va nous mobiliser
comme dit jean marc et il a raison il
faut il faut quelque chose qui fasse
rêver les jours quoi parce que sinon
c'est quoi
en espagne premier ministre et son
ministre du développement viennent de
rejoindre le pacte les pays bas sont un
pays qui se motive énormément
actuellement sur sur tous ces sujets là
la belgique on essaye de de faire
quelques on essaye de pierre larrouturou
interviendra devant un groupe de députés
un franco allemande au mois de juillet
on essaye de retrait
de convaincre et on a plusieurs
signataires au bundestag
que vous dire d'autre au niveau européen
je pense qu'on peut avec une petit
groupe fort on peut on peut y arriver à
condition de d'être unis et de profiter
de l'élan qui est en train de se perdre
que le gouvernement veut porter en ce
moment il ya une fenêtre de tir et c'est
possible avec bon là donc le projet de
traité qui est en cours de rédaction
avec dont j'ai mentionné moratinos et de
schutter d'ailleurs vous pouvez vous
êtes invités à rejoindre tous ces
groupes de travail pourrait fournir ces
pourrait fournir cette réponse ok merci
marche de fresnes de l'oscd lagence de
l'énergie nucléaire ma question sera
courte elle sera quelque part dans la
continuation de la question juste
précédent qui parlait des renouvelables
quelle est la position du chiffre
project en particulier sur le gaz vous
avez parlé effectivement de la
problématique du charbon il faut en
sortir la probable du pétrole on sait
pas très bien où on en est on a entendu
un autre écho la quelle est votre
position sur le sur le gaz ce qu'il n'y
a pas de renouvelables sans gaz à ce que
alors lorsque le gaz c'est bon alors on
n'a pas de position sur les objets on a
des positions sur les actions dit
autrement une action est bien à partir
du moment où elle permet de remplacer
quelque chose qui émet par quelque chose
qui aimait - et que ça ne crée pas une
impasse pour remplacer par quelque chose
qui émet encore moins quand on est dans
le timing qui est le nôtre
donc si aux gens si demain matin on
devait décider de mettre à la ferraille
les centrales à charbon allemandes et
polonaises pour les remplacer par des
centrales à gaz qui dure trente ans en
prenant par ailleurs l'engagement que
dans trente ans au moment où les
déconstruit on les remplace par du
nucléaire ou des renouvelables et que
tout ça s'inscrit dans la trajectoire
qui va bien va bien voilà donc on n'a
pas de position dogmatique sur rien par
contre s'il s'agit en france de
remplacer du nucléaire par un ensemble
et au lien plus gaz
on est content parce qu'il s'agit à ce
moment de faire monter les émissions
donc ça on n'a pas de position sur le
l'énergie en tant que tel je vais vous
donner un autre exemple qui va dans le
même sens moi j'ai pas à titre personnel
d'opposition est ce que les polonais
continue à avoir des centrales à charbon
s'ils sont d'accord pour mettre le co2
dans un trou dérange pas s'ils disent le
temps que nos mineurs se reconvertissent
ce qui prend une génération en gros vous
arrêter d'embaucher vous attendez que
c'est bon bref
eh bien on va continuer à utiliser du
charbon mais on mêle co2 dans un trou
parce que nous toucher au sous sol on
s'en fout ça nous dérange pas en
l'occurrence les polonais ça les dérange
pas et on a les moyens technologiques
pour faire ça ça me va très bien
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
idéologiquement il n'y a pas une
opposition contre ceux ci et contre cela
et une volonté par un coup de baguette
magique de faire alice au pays des
merveilles demain matin on sait très
bien que le monde est un parfait du
reste à chaque fois je me regarde dans
la glace je suis profondément convaincu
donc c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
de savoir si on est capable de se mettre
sur la dynamique qui va bien et c'est au
regard de cette dynamique qu'il faut
juger la cohérence des actions s'est pas
au regard des objets je vais revenir sur
la finance à cause de ça le groupe qui
va s'occuper du verdissement de la
finance la l'europe
j'ai très très peur je le redis qu'il
conclut que c'est les objets qu'il faut
financer
je suis désolé quand on finance de
l'éolien en allemagne pour remplacer du
nucléaire on n'a pas fait avancer le
problème d'un iota pas d'un iota
donc le à aucun titre
donc le sujet encore une fois il est
dans l'action
il n'est pas dans l'objet je vais vous
donner un autre exemple qui a rien à
voir avec le gaz fassi s'est encore du
gaz en l'occurrence comme dirait pumba
il s'agit des vaches
je rappelle qu'elle roth on a fait une
proposition au shift alors qu'il ne
donne pas le nombre qui dans l'esprit
dit ça il faut en europe est donc
particulièrement en france
si on veut être sérieux sur la question
des émissions agricoles diviser le
cheptel bovin par deux la question ce
n'est pas de tuer les éleveurs demain
matin il faut un métier beaucoup plus
dur que la totalité des gens qui sont
dans cette salle la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on leur permet de
vivre avec moins de vaches en gagnant
aussi bien voire mieux leur vie et donc
c'est quoi les contreparties qu'il faut
mettre en face pour que le système
flotte
bon voilà donc au ces mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on est contre les vagues d'une
manière générale qu'il ya des gens qui
sont vegan montrait bien il ya aussi des
gens qui peuvent juste manger deux fois
moins de viande et ils sont pavées
gagnent donc enfin voilà donc on n'a pas
de position dogmatique sur l'objet mais
j'insiste sur le fait que dans le monde
financier s'est considérablement plus
facile de gérer des objets que de gérer
des actions parce que si vous gérez des
actions faut doubler la compta donc il
faut créer 200 milles comptable du
carbone dans ce pays et ça ça fait des
coups et ils n'ont pas envie de ça alors
que gérer deux objets vous faites ça à
coût constant et à moyens constants
et quoi qu'on en dise moi je les connais
bien les financiers c'est mes clients
ils peuvent vous raconter tout ce qui
vole quand il s'agit de dépenser 50
mille euros pour faire un boulot sérieux
vous avez plus grand monde pour cette
fois c'est vrai ça donne à question de
en tout cas en public bonjour en fait ma
question c'est plutôt parce que là on
est en train depuis le début de
organiser un peu on va on pourrait faire
si on pourrait faire ça ce serait mieux
de faire comme ça mais en fait moi la
première chose que je me dis c'est en
fait moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'on
a en face de nous un énorme et ni
monstrueux quand je pourrais appeler le
capitaine le capitalisme financier et
dans le but est de faire le plus de
profit possible et jusque là on leur a
dit depuis des décennies faites ce que
vous voulez le marché va tout arranger
donc à esi produisent et vendent leurs
parents on nous dit la même chose aux
consommateurs oui tout à fait et en plus
on le dit aux consommateurs acheter tout
ce que vous voulez méchants banquiers
messac
voilà ça engendre est en fait d énormes
entreprises multinationales tout ce
qu'on veut qui polluent total etc et
donc du coup en fait je me dis on va
devoir lutter contre contre ça contre un
lobbying monstrueux en face qui va
vouloir défendre son pré carré à qui on
a dit pendant des décennies faites ce
que vous voulez il n'y a pas de problème
polluée et puis en plus ce sont des gens
qui appartiennent
même classe sociale que nos dirigeants
quoi donc ils parlent le même langage
ils se comprennent entre eux le voilà
les limites de la physique pour eux ça
leur parle beaucoup moins que et donc
voilà ma question c'est comment lutter
contre un monstre qui va mettre toutes
ses forces pour pouvoir continuer à
gagner et engendré autant de profits
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on lutte est ce
qu'on lutte contre un monstre qui veut
se lancer
la réponse est difficilement est très
difficilement
c'est évident difficilement est très
difficilement alors moi je suis d'accord
avec vous sur le fait que la
financiarisation de l'économie est un
problème c'est un problème parce que ça
a raccourci les horizons de temps c'est
un problème parce que ça a mis en
compétition par la magie des électrons
qui font le tour de la planète
n'importe quel lieu de production avec
n'importe quel autre lieu de production
dès lors que vous avez des trucs qui se
déplace et même dès lors que vous avez
la possibilité de comparer des
rentabilités en fonction de là où vous
investissez donc aujourd'hui la finance
fait que si vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir 10 % de rendement sur capitaux
investis en investissant dans as qui se
trouve en indonésie ça vous dissuadera
d'investir dans bay qui se trouvent en
belgique qui vous propose que 9%
c'est exactement ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui il hoche la tête
je les ai en face de moi les gens qui
font ça donc je vois bien donc si on met
pas des forces de fraude pardon oui mais
le risque
ouais mais enfin tout ça reste beaucoup
plus élevé que le zéro qu'il faut avoir
dans un monde stable donc le donc le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya on a
créé un système qui par ailleurs n'a pas
d'instances de régulation qui a pas de
maître du monde ou que dès que vous avez
une organisation transnationale elle n'a
pas d'instances de régulation ou des
instances de régulation extrêmement
molle donc le ca explique pourquoi
aujourd'hui on a créé un système qui est
extrêmement difficile à faire évoluer
rapidement dans une direction donnée
parce que la direction rapides dans une
direction donnée en général c'est que
vous avez un chef vocale vous n'êtes pas
capable de résister c'est comme ça que
vous l'avez la direction rapides quand
c'est vous même le chef
et que vous vous êtes capable de
résister à plein d'autres c'est
compliqué de vous de vous contraindre
donc il y aurait alors on peut faire
l'inventaire à la prévert tous les trucs
qu'il faudrait faire pour que le système
fred pour y interdire les comptes
trimestriels des entreprises on pourrait
interdire la cotation en continu
voilà alors mais c'est dur on veut que
parce que ou et où est le chef qui va
décider de trucs comme ça
bon voilà donc c'est vous avez raison c
est la seule démarche qui au nouveau
shift nous semble être un truc qu'on
peut tenter au sens de on se dit qu'on
sera peut-être utile à quelque chose en
faisant ça c'est pas du tout si ça
sauvera le monde c'est d'essayer de
crantée marche après marche un peu à
l'anglais des trucs qui sont
susceptibles d'infléchir un peu le
système marche après marche jusqu'au
moment où il arrive quelque chose qui
n'a fléchi en grand est ce qu'il va
fléchir à en grand c'est pas l'économie
c'est la norme sociale
dit autrement le fait que un jour la
finance se réoriente de manière très
significative ses six pour la majeure
partie des pays du monde émettent du co2
dans l'atmosphère est juste un truc qui
ne se fait pas exactement comme ça ne se
fait pas de tuer votre voisin d'accord
il faut il faut que ça devienne quelque
chose qui ne se fait pas et c'est pas
une affaire de jeu je paye je passais
juste ça se fait pas voilà c'est voilà
jour on en arrive là
en fait vous avez régler votre problème
mais il faut en arriver là tout à fait
d'accord sur ce changement de paradigme
juste peau pour répondre sur la dérive
financière dont vous parlez moi j'ai
rien contre et je suis tout aussi
capitaliste que bonvoisin j'ai rien
contre les profits investi d'une
entreprise elle avait mais le problème
de la le problème de la bulle financière
dont on parlait tout à l'heure c'est que
les investissements ne se font pas les
placements de se font de moins en moins
dans l'économie réelle ou peut-être
parce qu'on ne sait plus où peut-être
parce qu'on manque d'idées d'opportunité
je ne sais mais est de plus en plus dans
des produits dérivés de dérivés de
dérivés avec une circulaire avec eux le
rapport de 1 à 10 dont je parlais tout à
l'heure sur la création monétaire des 3
dernières années et pour moi la
transition énergétique est un des moyens
de donner du sens de redonner du sens à
la fois aux populations à l'europe et de
casse
et quelque part de répondre à ces
folie que l'on ne sait plus où investir
merci beaucoup à vous deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]